Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur 24. Ausgabe unserer Gesprächsreihe über Wissenschaft, die Arbeit der Wissenschaft. Viele Aspekte haben wir hier schon besprochen. Und gerade in letzter Zeit sind wir hier auf einen Weg eingeschert, den ich auch persönlich sehr interessant finde. Die Hinterfragung auch vieler Fragen in Bezug auf Nachhaltigkeit auf der einen Seite, aber eben auch auf die konkrete Auswirkung wissenschaftlicher Arbeit auf die Welt. Sowohl was die Schaffung von Probleme betrifft als auch die Wegschaffung von Probleme. Und so wird es auch heute sein, nachdem wir hier schon auch viel insbesondere über chemische Aspekte gesprochen haben.
Zum Beispiel in der Ausgabe Nummer 12 übre Energieforschung oder Ausgabe 19 mit dem Cradle-to-Cradle-Konzept, wollen wir uns heute eines Themas annehmen, was – aktuell wäre wahrscheinlich gar nicht die richtige Bezeichnung, sondern eigentlich ein sehr offensichtliches Problem ist weltweit. Es geht um Wasser. Um die Verteilung von Wasser, um die Nutzung von Wasser und die Probleme, die am Wasser dranhängen. Und um darüber ausführlich zu sprechen, begrüße ich Dr. Klaus Kümmerer. Schönen guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Willkommen bei Forschergeist. Wir befinden uns im Übrigen gerade in Lüneburg. Konkret an der Leuphana Universität in Lüneburg. Wenn ich es richtig sehe, ist es das Institut für nachhaltige Chemie und Umweltchemie, ist richtig und da sind Sie der Direktor davon und haben hier eine Professor für ja im Prinzip genau diesen Bereich, nachhaltige Chemie und stoffliche Ressourcen, wie es so schön heißt. Aber das Wasser ist Ihr spezielles Thema, richtig?
Ja, Wasser ist einerseits spezielles Thema, Ausgangspunkt, so mein Interesse, hängt vielleicht damit zusammen, ich bin auf dem Land aufgewachsen und ich habe nie einen Kindergarten von Innen gesehen, ich war aber viel draußen, auch an Bächen gespielt und da war Wasser eigentlich schon immer ein Faszinosum. Und ja immer wieder darauf zurückkommend im Lauf der Zeit. Verschmutzung von Wasser durch chemische Stoffe, das zu lernen, da beizutragen, was drüber zu wissen. Und irgendwann hat sich die Frage gestellt, wie kann man das verhindern? Darüber gearbeitet ganz klassisch im Umfeld von Abwasserreinigung und ähnlichen Dingen. Und später dann auch die Frage, was gibt es eigentlich für andere Ansätze, außer Abwasserreinigung? Auch getrieben davon, dass wir zwar hier in der Regel relativ wasserreiches Land sind, aber auch bei uns gibt es ??? trockene Sommerbereiche, wo es nicht so viel Wasser gibt.
Denken Sie an das Umfeld von Frankfurt oder denken Sie an Teile von Brandenburg. Oder jetzt nach dem wasserarmen Herbst, wo man ja an verschiedenen Teilen, Bereichen sieht, dass Wasser doch knapp werden könnte. Bis hin zu, dass man einzelne Gehöfte im Schwarzwald mit Wasser versorgen musste. Daraus folgen dann auch ein weiterer Blick, wie sieht es eigentlich in der Welt aus, wo man ja auch wasserreiche, aber gleichzeitig wasserarme Gebiete haben, wo viel diskutiert wird und wurde. Muss nur an die Entwicklungsziele denken. Der Nachhaltigkeit, Development-Goals, UN die kürzlich verabschiedet wurden, da ist Wasser ein wesentlicher Punkt. Aber nicht nur die Menge, sondern eben auch die Qualität.
Bleiben wir doch nochmal ganz kurz bei dieser kitaarmen Zeit am Bach, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Wann hat sich denn für Sie überhaupt herausgebildet, dass Sie wissenschaftlich arbeiten wollen?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Ja dass ich mehr von der Welt lernen und verstehen wollte, ja das gab es glaube ich schon relativ früh. Auch in der Schule haben mich die Naturwissenschaften interessiert, stark interessiert und ja dieses – man könnte es jetzt hochtrabend formulieren – das faustische ein bisschen mehr zu erkennen, was die Welt zusammenhält, also war ein Thema. Mich hat Physik interessiert, aber immer auch darüber hinausgehend damals schon so philosophische Aspekte oder also nicht nur das eigentliche Fach verstehen, sondern auch was steckt eigentlich noch dahinter. Kosmologie, Weltmodelle, solche Dinge. Erst später bin ich dann mal mit den Lichtenbergschen Sudelbüchern in Kontakt gekommen, wo unter anderem dann ein so Gedanke, ein Aphorismus von ihm drinsteht, da habe ich schon Chemie studiert, wer nur die Chemie versteht, versteht auch die nicht, so sinngemäß.
Und da habe ich gemerkt, ja das ist genau das, was eigentlich auch mein Motto ist. Also Chemie verstehen, wirklich gut verstehen und total spannend, aber immer auch die Frage, Chemie wofür, für wen und was bedeutet das? Wenn man neue Materialien, neue Stoffe machen, neue Produkte, völlig faszinierend und dann natürlich in der Zeit auch schon die ersten Fragen danach, wie lange können wir das machen? Club of Rome war zwar schon ein paar Jahre alt, paar wenige, als ich mit der Schule fertig war. Aber natürlich Umweltverschmutzung war ein Thema, die Diskussion über Kernenergie war ein Thema.
Wir sind jetzt in den 70er Jahren richtig?
Wir sind jetzt Ende der 70er Jahre ja.
Da war ja Chemie ein heißes Eisen in der öffentlichen Diskussion. Die Verschmutzung der Flüsse. Da hat ja sozusagen das wilde Wachstum der Bundesrepublik Deutschland deutliche Spuren hinterlassen. Waldsterben dann noch in den Anfängen der 80er Jahre. Was ja im Prinzip auch ein extremer Antrieb war auch für das Aufkommen der Umweltaktivisten. Letztlich auch der Bildung der grünen Partei etc. Wie haben Sie das wahrgenommen? Also welche Rolle hat das für Sie gespielt, wie  haben Sie das gesehen?
Ich habe das wahrgenommen schon im Sinne, da muss man was tun, da ist vielleicht eine Gefahr. Das kann so nicht weitergehen. Aber ich habe es auch wahrgenommen im Sinne von, es nützt nichts, das alles zu verteufeln, sondern wir müssen es verstehen, wir müssen genau hinschauen. Ich bin dann deshalb auch dann nach dem Studium, auch während des Studiums habe ich mich ein bisschen engagiert, im Sinne von Bürgerwissenschaft und nach dem Studium dann erst mal aus der Hochschule raus, aus der Universität nach der Promotion. Habe auch während dem oder vor dem Studium, während dem Studium auch verschiedene Praktika gemacht, in die Industrie zu gucken, wie denken die Leute und was wird auch konkret an Chemie gemacht und nicht nur an der Hochschule, aber auch. Wie denken die Leute, weil die sind ja auch nicht dumm und überlegen sich was, bei dem was sie machen. Und bin dann nach der Promotion eben erst mal weg von Universität, was für viele nicht so ganz verständlich war.
Aber mir war es wichtig, auch noch etwas anderes zu sehen und war dann beim Öko-Institut in Freiburg. Bin dort aber auch hin – und das war damals noch nicht selbstverständlich in dem Bereich Chemie – wo ich gesagt habe, wenn ich zu euch komme, dann will ich aber auch, dass man den Kontakt und die Diskussion auf einer sachlichen Ebene beispielsweise mit der chemischen Industrie sucht. Und da hat sich dann auch raus gestellt, dass ich da auch nicht alleine war. Und dann haben wir in der Richtung habe ich da einige Projekte gemacht, einige Arbeiten gemacht. Chemiepolitischer Dialog. Wo unter anderem auch in diesem Kontext es verschiedene Tagungen gab, unter anderem in Tutzingen. Und bei einer dieser Tagungen, wo man eigentlich eher über die Folgen der Umweltverschmutzung gesprochen hat durch Abwässer, durch Abluft, worum es hauptsächlich ja damals ging. Und damals war dann ein Herr, Herr Weise aus dem Vorstand der Bayer AG mit dabei.
Und der hat dann damals gesagt – und ich fand das ziemlich mutig einerseits und revolutionär, vielleicht hing es damit zusammen, weil er bald in den Ruhestand ging – ja wir können hier viel über Abfallstoffe und Abwasser und Abluft diskutieren, aber die eigentlichen Produkte, die eigentlichen Emissionen der chemischen Industrie sind ja die Produkte. Und da liegt das Problem. Und das hat vieles vorweggenommen und das hat mich nicht mehr losgelassen, darüber nachzudenken, was das eigentlich heißt und wie man damit umgehen kann.
Wie haben Sie dann den Weg hierher gefunden?
Ja ich wollte dann wieder an die Hochschule, an die Universität zurück, war dann an der Universität Freiburg auch nochmal. Nicht in die Chemie, sondern ich war dann in der Medizin. Weil mich beschäftigt hat, ja Zufälle spielen eben häufig eine Rolle, jemand kennengelernt aus der Uniklinik, den Leiter des Institut für Umweltmedizin und Krankenhaushygiene damals und da sind wir im Gespräch drauf gekommen, was passiert eigentlich mit all den Arzneimitteln, die die Menschen ausscheiden und damals noch viel mehr interessiert, welche Rolle spielen da eigentlich die Kliniken? Also auch da war ich sozusagen nicht ganz typisch wieder. Ich habe nochmal einen Bereich gesucht, wo man eigentlich als Chemiker nicht so hingeht und man ist dann fachfremd. Und wenn man als Chemiker in die Medizin geht, dann eigentlich eher in die biochemische Forschung. Und insofern Ihre Frage vorhin, wann das Interesse für die Wissenschaft, immer, aber noch nicht ausgeprägt für eine wissenschaftliche Karriere.
Ich habe mich eher davon leiten lassen, Dinge zu machen, die mich interessieren, die ich spannend finde. Spannend auch im Sinne von herausfordernd, oder die ich besser verstehen wollte. Und da ging es dann unter anderem drum, mal zu überlegen. War ich da in der Uniklinik relativ lange dann und habe mich dann auch damit beschäftigt, wo werden welche Mengen an Arzneimitteln eigentlich eingesetzt, wo verbleiben sie? Eben es wird ein Großteil zum Teil unverändert ausgeschieden, dessen war ich mir vorher auch nicht so bewusst. Die gehen dann ins Abwasser und was passiert dann? Dann haben wir angefangen, Abbaubarkeit von diesen Stoffen zu untersuchen und so kam eins zum anderem. Dann haben wir festgestellt, viele sind nicht abbaubar und dann zwischenzeitlich ist das auch ein größeres Thema geworden, das an anderen Stellen entstanden ist, aber auch zum Teil durch unsere Arbeiten mit angestoßen.
Dann gab es Nachweise von Arzneimitteln in der Umwelt. Eine Sache, von der wir lange Zeit gar nicht wussten, parallel in Berlin hatte eine Gruppe einen Arzneimittelwirkstoff im Grundwasser entdeckt aus einer Altlast. Wo sie zuerst gedacht haben, das sei der Überrest eines Pflanzenschutzmittels und so ging dann die ganze Diskussion los und war dann nach 10 Jahren ein weltweites Thema. Ein Hype-Thema, was mich dann unter anderem dazu veranlasst hat, zu sagen, also gut das ist jetzt ein Thema, das machen jetzt viele und dann war es für mich aber – ich sage das mal so – nicht mehr so ganz interessant. Und die Dinge, die mich interessiert haben, nämlich und deshalb war ich damals auch in der Uniklinik genau richtig, was kann ich an der Quelle machen? Es gab viele Veröffentlichungen, die dann Arzneimittel in der Umwelt nachgewiesen haben. Ja ist schön und erreicht viel Öffentlichkeit, viel mehr als so komische Bilanzierungen und Fragen an der Quelle. Aber letztlich war ich interessiert, ja wie können wir das Problem angehen?
Und dann ist auch losgegangen irgendwann, das brauchte eine Weile, dass man gesagt hat, ja wir müssen uns mit Abwasserreinigung beschäftigen. Dann kam die Diskussion, wir brauchen erweiterte Abwasserreinigung. Also wir haben bei uns hier drei Stufen in normalen Abwasserreinigungen. Die mechanische Stufe und dann die biologische Stufe. Der Hauptteil, wo Bakterien Stoffe abbauen, Schadstoffe abbauen. Wobei die ursprüngliche Konzeption der Kläranlage ja ist, dass sie menschliche Ausscheidungen entfernt und nicht irgendwelche synthetischen Chemikalien. Und dann muss man sich auch nicht wundern, dass das nicht so einfach geht und die Bakterien dort eben nicht alles abbauen zu Kohlendioxid und Wasser, sprich vollständig mineralisieren. Man hatte ja auch vorher schon gewusst von Schadstoffen, die sozusagen unbeabsichtigt entstanden sind, wie Dioxine oder polizyklische aromatische Kohlenwasserstoffe, dass wir die im Klärschlamm finden.
Dass wir zum Teil auch manche chemischen Produkte im Klärschlamm finden, die Moleküle und dann kamen die Arzneimittel noch dazu und die endokrin wirksamen Stoffe, also die hormonartig wirkenden Stoffe. Und dann hat man gemerkt, und all dieses kriegen wir ja gar nicht raus vollständig. Müssen wir also mehr machen, also eine vierte Stufe wurde dann erforscht und da ist man dann mit verschiedenen Mitteln dran, aber auch chemischer Sicht war mir relativ schnell klar, das kann eigentlich nicht funktionieren. Und das ist zwischenzeitlich der Stand der Diskussion.  Und deshalb hat mich schon relativ früh interessiert, wenn man jetzt von dieser End of the Pipe, die Behandlung am Ende des Rohres, weggehen, was können wir eigentlich am Anfang des Rohres machen oder wie Albert Einstein mal so schön gesagt hat, wenn es denn wirklich von ihm ist, ein schlauer Mensch löst ein Problem, ein weiser vermeidet es.
Sind wir jetzt schon in Lüneburg in ???
Jetzt sind wir noch nicht in Lüneburg.
Das war sozusagen jetzt alles noch die Tätigkeit an dieser Uni, die das geprägt hat?
In Freiburg ja. Und zu der Zeit stellte sich dann auch die Frage, oder war für mich klar, ich will eigentlich auch von dieser umweltchemischen Sichtweise weg und dann kam an anderer Stelle, ausgehend von Produktionsverbesserungen, Abfälle sparen, Energiesparen, die grüne Chemie als Diskussionspunkt und in Deutschland auch eine Diskussion über aus politischen Gründen nicht grüne, sondern nachhaltige Chemie auf und das war dann genau der Bereich, der mich da beschäftigt, wo ich mich dann ein Stück weit wiedergefunden habe. Allerdings war und ist zum großen Teil der Fokus da immer noch auf, wie kann ich bessere Synthesen machen und dadurch Ressourcen sparen, weniger Abfälle erzeugen, ist natürlich auch ökonomisch getrieben. Ich habe dann während der Zeit im Ökoinstitut auch noch so Dinge gemacht wie Ökobilanzen und Produktlinienanalysen. Haben mich mit Risiko und Zeit beschäftigt, alles Dinge, die man eigentlich dann nicht so einfach machen sollte, wenn man eine klare akademische Karriere plant.
Und all dieses zusammengenommen hat dann dazu geführt, dass die Frage einfach im Raum stand, ja wie jetzt weiter, jetzt wissen wir, die Stoffe sind in der Umwelt und dann ergab sich die Möglichkeit, hierher zu kommen nach Lüneburg. Da wurde aus verschiedenen Gründen heraus eine Fakultät Nachhaltigkeit gegründet. Eine interdisziplinäre, das heißt ich arbeite hier nicht nur mit Chemikern zusammen, sondern auch mit Biologien, aber vor allen Dingen auch haben wir Ökonomen, wir haben Umweltrechtler, wir haben Politikwissenschaften in einer Fakultät unter der Überschrift Nachhaltigkeitsforschung.
Weil das eine sich ohne das andere gar nicht zu Ende denken lässt?
So ist es ja. Weil sonst als Techniker oder Chemiker bleibe ich dann nur sozusagen bei den chemischen Lösungen stehen und kann vielleicht Stoffe verbessern. Aber wenn diese Stoffe dann im Sinne der nachhaltigen Chemie so gemacht sind, dass sie zwar eine gute Synthese haben und vielleicht Ressourcenaspekte auch noch beachtet werden, aber ich nicht im Blick habe, dass sie vielleicht für einen Zweck eingesetzt sind, der mit Nachhaltigkeit gar nichts zu tun hat, dann ist das eigentlich messerscharf am Ziel vorbeigeschossen. Und alles für die Katz. Und deshalb ist auch mein Verständnis von nachhaltiger Chemie, also grüne Chemie, green Chemistry, dass man sagt, wie kann ich Chemie insgesamt nachhaltiger machen? Von der Rohstoffgewinnung – und da geht es ja schon los, da gibt es jede Menge ökonomische Aspekte, da gibt es aber auch soziale Aspekte, geopolitische Aspekte - über die Herstellung der Produkte, über den Vertrieb, ihre Anwendung bis zu ihrem Verbleib.
Seien das jetzt Arzneimittel als einzelne Moleküle oder Flammschutzmittel, die unbeabsichtigt ins Abwasser gehen. Denken Sie an Kosmetika, Shampoo, wenn Sie heute morgen geduscht haben, machen Sie ja nichts falsches. Das geht quasi bestimmungsgemäß in die Umwelt. Oder wenn wir komplexe Materialien machen. Denken wir an Solarzellen, wie können wir die hinterher wiedergewinnen? Was steckt da an Stoffen drin? Und da habe ich immer entlang es gesamten Lebenswegs habe ich immer auch die ökonomischen Aspekte, habe politische Aspekte. Und das führt dann zu der Frage sozusagen, wie kann Chemie mit guten Produkten zur Nachhaltigkeit beitragen? Und das ist dann erst nachhaltige Chemie.
Ich will nochmal kurz nachhaken, dieser Aufbau dieses Instituts. Also diese Kombination verschiedener Disziplinen. Das ist ja nicht unbedingt der traditionelle Ansatz, wie Institute oder überhaupt Forschungsbereiche an Universitäten aufgestellt sind. Das ist relativ – weiß nicht, ob das das richtige Wort ist – modern, aber ist das ein Trend und wie ändert das sozusagen die Arbeit?
Ja also ich habe vorhin über die Fakultät gesprochen, aber Sie haben Recht, ein Stück weit spiegelt sich das auch im Institut oder in meiner Arbeitsgruppe. Das heißt ich habe jetzt im Moment zwar nicht all die Disziplinen, aber im Laufe der Zeit, es waren Ingenieure, es sind zum Teil auch noch Physiker, Biologen, Limnologen, Pharmazeuten. Ich habe Kooperationen mit Kollegen hier dann an der Fakultät, wo es um Bildung geht, Ausbildung geht, wie vermittle ich Wissen. Wir haben immer Praxispartner gehabt, mit denen wir das zusammen gemacht haben, aber ja das verändert sehr stark. Weil man gucken muss, wie definiere ich mich? Wissenschaftler definieren sich ja gern über eine ganz spezifische Expertise. Und der erste Punkt, aber das ging schon früh los zu Beginn meiner Habilitation, habe ich Biologen, Mikrobiologen gehabt, um die biologische Abbaubarkeit von Stoffen besser zu verstehen, ich habe von denen viel gelernt. Also mein Selbstverständnis war dann nicht mehr, ich als der Leiter der Arbeitsgruppe bin der, der in allem der Experte ist und von allem am besten Bescheid weiß.
Sondern ich habe mein eigenes Spezialgebiet, aber und ich muss dafür sorgen, dass wenn ich verschiedene Disziplinen in meiner Arbeitsgruppe habe, dass die miteinander sprechen und sich austauschen und zusammenarbeiten. Und dass ich das auch verstehe. Und ich habe das dann irgendwann als Chance begriffen, vieles zu lernen. Wie schon gesagt, wer nur von Chemie was versteht, versteht auch die nicht. Es gibt so viele spannende Dinge auf dieser Welt. Und das dann eben auch in die Arbeitsgruppe reintragen. Aber klar sind wir jetzt nicht diejenigen, die im Bereich der Analytik diejenigen sind, die da die besten Publikationen machen. Die fortgeschrittenste Analytik haben oder die ausgefuchstesten Methoden. Sondern wir kommen immer erst ein bisschen später, wenn das sozusagen läuft und gucken, was brauchen wir. Also auch in meiner Arbeitsgruppe gibt es eine Gruppe, die beschäftigt sich mit Abbau, biologischem Abbau, aber durch Licht von Stoffen und dann gibt es Analytik, um zu gucken, was bleibt da übrig, was kann man daraus lernen.
Und dann gibt es eine Gruppe, die sich mit Toxikologie auskennt, die sich damit beschäftigt, welche Eigenschaften haben denn diese Stoffe im Sinne von Wirkung. Wenn ein Stoff unvollständig abgebaut wird, wie bei der erweiterten Abwasserreinigung oder bei der Zersetzung in der Umwelt. Und es gibt eine Gruppe, die sich beschäftigt mit, jetzt haben wir Stoffe, die wir eigentlich gar nicht kaufen können, diese Abbauprodukte. Wie kann ich da Eigenschaften erheben? Und da gibt es Chemieinformatik. Also man kann heutzutage, wenn man eine Strukturformel hat, Eigenschaften von Stoffen rechnen, mehr oder weniger gut, hängt davon ab, welche Eigenschaft das ist. Sei es Wasserlöslichkeit, Verteilung in der Umwelt, aber auch Toxizität, ist der Stoff kanzerogen? Löst der Krebs aus? Und das haben wir auch in der Gruppe. Und das kommt alles zusammen. Das heißt auf eine Art und Weise mache ich immer noch Umweltchemie. Aber die Schlussfolgerungen, die ich daraus ziehe sind andere und wie ich das Wissen anwende.
Nämlich genau der Frage ganz am Anfang des Rohres sind die Moleküle, wie kann ich sie so, bevor ich sie überhaupt synthetisiere, gestalten, dass sie bestimmte Eigenschaften haben, Anwendungseigenschaften, Funktionalität nennen wir das, die vielleicht sogar besser ist, als das Molekül sie hat, das ersetzt werden soll, aber gleichzeitig andere Eigenschaften, die für die Nachhaltigkeit wichtig sind. Beispielsweise wenn sie in die Umwelt gelangen, dass sie da schnell und vollständig abbaubar sind. Dass ich gar keine Kläranlage brauche oder keine vierte Stufe. Und dann haben wir den weiteren Bereich der Nachhaltigkeit. Nämlich, dass das weltweit anwendbar ist sozusagen.
Also im Prinzip ist diese interdisziplinäre Arbeit führt, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, so zu einer erhöhten kombinatorischen Vorleistung im Prinzip in den Auswirkungen, die zwar jetzt nicht in dem spitz definierten Forschungsbereichen sich sozusagen am Maximum orientiert, aber vielleicht auf der anderen Seite auf bessere Rezepte oder überhaupt erst mal auch Lösungsansätze liefert, die in der Industrie oder auch in den Kommunen sehr viel konkreter umgesetzt werden kann, weil die letztlich zu einer tatsächlichen Auswirkung führenden Schlüsse zumindest teilweise auch schon angedacht sind?
Ja, aber auch da nochmal am Anfang, das ist natürlich auch intellektuell total spannend. Es ist eine Herausforderung, sowohl für einen selbst, andere zu verstehen. Ich habe auch mal eine Zeit lang in Freiburg noch ein Seminar gemacht mit einer Philosophin. Wir haben erst mal ein Jahr gebraucht, bis wir uns überhaupt richtig verstanden haben. Natürlich haben wir deutsch gesprochen das war nicht das Problem, aber was verstehe ich unter einem System?
Erst mal eine Terminologie aufsetzen.
Terminologie aufsetzen. Und das ist eine große Herausforderung ist ein Mehraufwand, den man natürlich auch als karrierehinderlich empfinden kann, aber es ist auch eine ungeheure Bereicherung, zu sehen, wie sehen andere die Welt. Und was folgt daraus, wenn man es zusammen sieht? Und das ist natürlich einerseits im kleinen in der Arbeitsgruppe ist immer wieder ein Punkt, die Doktoranden, die neu kommen, die müssen das trotz allem Interesse meistens erst mal lernen. Hoppla, da kommt ja einer aus der Sicht der Pharmazie, der hat eine andere Sicht als ich, als Chemiker beispielsweise. Und das ist jetzt noch relativ nah beieinander. Und das muss man immer wieder organisieren und immer wieder Zeit aufwenden, aber es eröffnet ganz neue Weltsichten. Bis hin zu dem was Sie gesagt haben, dass man vielleicht auf ganz andere Lösungen kommt und ich würde mal sagen, die Chemieindustrie und auch die Kommunen sind in der Breite da noch nicht so weit. Und auch die Chemie als Wissenschaft ist da noch nicht so weit. Also mir geht es auch nicht drum, zu sagen, alle müssen das so machen. Wir brauchen nach wie vor Leute, die sehr gut synthetisieren können.
Hat sich eigentlich die Universität hier in Lüneburg da irgendwann neu aufgestellt oder ist das etwas, was hier ohnehin schon immer so verfolgt wurde?
Ja Lüneburg ist ja jetzt nicht die bekannte Exzellenzuniversität. Sondern Lüneburg ist nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg gegründet worden, zur Lehrerausbildung hauptsächlich. Und war dann bis Mitte der 80er noch gar keine Universität und war auch danach eine regionale Universität und gehört auch so ein bisschen in den Reigen der Neugründungen von kleinen neuen Universitäten auch in Niedersachsen. Und man stand dann, soweit ich das verstanden habe, Anfang der 2000er Jahre vor dem Problem, wollen wir wirklich so viele Universitäten haben kleine, relativ unbedeutende oder wollen wir was anderes haben? Müssen wir vielleicht welche schließen? Klar, es ging sicher auch um finanzielle Überlegungen. Und da hat sich die Universität Lüneburg unter anderem auch ja neu erfunden, im Sinne von, dass damals schon Umweltnachhaltigkeit, Nachhaltigkeit ist ja schon länger ein Thema, wenn man den Brundtland-Bericht denkt, Ende der 80er.
Dass man gesagt hat, ja wir müssen uns neu aufstellen, wenn wir überleben wollen. Wir brauchen vielleicht auch eine Nische oder einen neuen Ansatzpunkt. Und da gab es hier ein Stück weit schon ein bisschen Tradition und dann war Nachhaltigkeit ist ein Thema. Eine der Folgen ist die Gründung dieser Fakultät. Das andere ist aber auch, dass Nachhaltigkeit ein Leitbild der ganzen Universität ist und auch Zivilgesellschaft als Leitbild. Wo man sagt, also eine Ausbildung von Studierenden, oder Bildung von Studierenden ist fachlich wichtig und muss gut sein, aber wir wollen nicht nur Studierende, die nachher abschließen, exzellent in ihrem Fach sind, aber kein Interesse dafür haben oder nicht wissen, was im Moment die aktuellen politischen Diskussionen sind und was das vielleicht für sie bedeutet oder wie sie sich vielleicht als Bürger vor Ort, da wo sie wohnen, einbringen können oder an der Institution, in denen sie arbeiten.
Na der Fokus auf die Nachhaltigkeit überrascht mich insofern nicht, als dass ja Lüneburg nun hier auch einerseits in einem stark durch Landwirtschaft geprägten Bundesland, Niedersachsen, angesiedelt ist, andererseits mit der Lüneburger Heide auch einen großen Naturpark besonderer Prägung vor der Tür hat. Ich will nicht sagen, das dominiert hier alles, aber das sind ja alles so Faktoren, die da nochmal mit reinkommen und wo man ja dann auch, weiß nicht, man denkt ja auch so, wo man ist und nicht immer unbedingt nur was das Thema ist. Das mag hier sicherlich die Arbeit auch mit beeinflussen oder?
Ich denke schon, also da war ich noch nicht da zu der Zeit, aber ich denke schon, dass das eine Rolle gespielt hat, die Nähe von Gorleben hat sicher auch eine Rolle gespielt. Könnte ich mir auch vorstellen auf dem Gelände, wo wir jetzt hier sind beispielsweise das war eine Kaserne der Briten bis glaube ich 91/92, die Universität gab es schon vorher, aber dann ist sie hierher gezogen. Also Schwerter zu Pflugscharen und ähnliche Dinge, das spielt sicher alles mit rein, ist nicht auszuschließen. Lüneburger Heide ist ein ganz spannendes Beispiel insofern, als die Lüneburger Heide, was wir heute schützen, ja das Ergebnis eines Raubbaues aus früheren Jahrhunderten ist. Lüneburg als Hansestadt war ja lange Zeit der Salzlieferant für die anderen Hansestädte, um beispielsweise Lebensmittel zu konservieren. Das hat dann irgendwann im 17. Jahrhundert aufgehört und von da ab war Lüneburg auch arm. Und dann nochmal mit der Zonengrenze nochmal arm. Und insofern ist das ein ganz interessantes Beispiel.
Wo ich noch gar nicht sagen soll, mit glücklichem Ausgang, aber zumindest mit überraschendem Ausgang. Weil vorher war das ja eigentlich alles Waldgebiet und nachher war es abgeholzt und kahl. Und jetzt schützen wir es und empfinden es als wertvoll. Die Frage ist sozusagen, brauchen wir, sollten wir immer diesen Umweg gehen und gibt es immer diesen glücklichen Zufall oder gibt es vielleicht auch systematischere Ansätze und kann man manche Dinge oder muss man manche Dinge nicht im Vorfeld einfach schon vermeiden.
Kommen wir mal auf das Kernthema dieser Sendung, das Wasser. Zwischendurch ist das schon angeklungen, aber sozusagen als wichtigster Baustein des Lebens, auch unseres Körpers und natürlich dann auch wichtiger Transportmechanismus des gesamten Ökosystems. Was ist denn so der Ist-Zustand Wasser in dieser Welt. Mit welchen Problemen hat dieser Planet derzeit zu kämpfen und was sind die Ursachen dafür?
Ein Problem ist die Menge des verfügbaren Wassers. Also weil wir feststellen, wir brauchen natürlich immer mehr Wasser. Wasser können wir eigentlich in dem Sinne nicht verbrauchen.
Ja wollte ich gerade sagen.
Wir gebrauchen immer mehr Wasser.  Und was uns jetzt hier anbelangt stellen wir auch fest, dass es immer häufiger auch mal zu Wasserknappheiten kommt, anscheinend über den Klimawandel. Weltweit stellen wir auch fest, dass es eine immer ungleichmäßigere Verteilung gibt. Ich habe einen Mitarbeiter aus Indien beispielsweise, der hat mir erst gestern erzählt, da gibt es jetzt Bereiche und das habe ich auch mitbekommen, weil in den Medien da gab es sintflutartige Überschwemmungen und gleichzeitig gibt es in diesem Land gar nicht so weit weg Bereiche, wo es seit drei Jahren nicht mehr geregnet hat. Was früher wohl häufiger der Fall war. Also diese Ungleichverteilung einfach mal geografisch und dann auch die Ungleichverteilung, wer kann sich wie viel Wasser leisten. Und was wesentlich auch mit rein spielt ist die Qualität des Wassers.
Die Qualität des Wassers, hygienischer Zustand, also Krankheitserreger, was kann als Trinkwasser direkt benutzt werden? Das sieht bei uns relativ gut aus, bei uns wenn man Wasser trinkt, selbst aus dem Bach, wird es häufig nicht so sein, dass man sofort umkippt, sondern wenn man Pech hat gibt es Bauchschmerzen, weil man ein paar Keime mit aufgenommen hat. In anderen Ländern sieht das ja ganz anders aus. Da wohnt der eine am Fluss und macht sein tägliches Geschäft und der nächste weiter unten wäscht 100-200 Meter weiter sein Geschirr. Die Bilder kennen wir alle. Da geht es gleich um hygienische Aspekte. Was wir aber bei uns auch feststellen, wenn wir zurückgehen vor 30-40 Jahren da hatten wir relativ wenige Stoffe. Relativ wenige in relativ hoher Konzentration in unseren Flüssen.
Was für Stoffe?
Da ging es auch schon um Arzneimittel, da ging es um Schwermetalle, da ging es um Bestandteile von Abwässern, unter anderem aus der chemischen Industrie. Auch aus der Landwirtschaft, man denke an die Gewässereutrophierung. Aus den Haushalten, gab es da …
Was heißt Gewässereutrophierung?
Überdüngung von Gewässern, was dann letzten Endes zu dem führt, was man so als Flusssterben oder Umkippen des Flusses kennt, wo es damals auch Bilder gab, alle Fische schwimmen oben, es ist eine stinkende Brühe. Solche Dinge, das haben wir alles nicht mehr. Dank der Fortschritte, der großen Fortschritte des technischen Umweltschutzes, des nachsorgenden Umweltschutzes. Mit dem wir ja jetzt an die Grenzen kommen, was wir unter anderem daran sehen, wir haben einerseits sehr viel mehr verschiedene chemische Stoffe, die in die Umwelt gelangen können. Wir haben etwa 100.000 verschiedene Stoffe in der Europäischen Union auf dem Markt. Es wird geschätzt, dass 30.000 davon in die Umwelt gelangen davon normalerweise und messen können wir vielleicht 500. Also wir haben sehr viel mehr und die Konzentrationen sind dank dessen, dass wir diesen technischen Umweltschutz haben, auch deutlich niedriger.
Also wir sprechen nicht mehr über Milligramm pro Liter, also 1000tel Gramm pro Liter, wir sprechen um einen Faktor Tausend oder Million weniger. Mikrogramm pro Liter oder Nanogramm pro Liter. Und da sind wir bei deutlich weniger. Also Milligramm pro Liter, das wäre ppm, Milligramm pro Kilogramm, part per million oder Preuße pro München, da kann man sich das etwa vorstellen. Und da sind wir jetzt nochmal und den Faktor Tausend oder noch mehr drunter. Also wir sprechen jetzt von Chinese pro China sozusagen oder Inder pro Indien. Das können wir heute gut messen. Also es geht nicht um akute Bedrohung oder Toxizität bei uns. Bei uns geht es vielleicht eher drum, und da haben wir vielleicht zunehmende Allergie, in manchen Bereichen zunehmende Krebshäufigkeit, weil wir zunehmend mit mehr Stoffen in Kontakt kommen, über längere Zeit in Kontakt kommen, das können wir aber nicht abschätzen. Wir haben keine Daten drüber, was bedeutet eine lebenslange Aufnahme von einem bestimmten Stoff in ganz niederer Konzentration.
Werden wir wahrscheinlich auch nie haben, wir können und wollen keine Menschenversuche machen. Aber all diese Abschätzungen der Risiken ist immer nur für einen Stoff. Wir haben keine oder nur ganz wenige Kenntnisse drüber, was bedeutet es, wenn wir mehreren Stoffen gleichzeitig ausgesetzt sind. Wir sehen es ein bisschen bei älteren Menschen, die häufig mehrere Medikamente gleichzeitig bekommen, dass da häufig oder immer häufiger unerwartete Nebenwirkungen auftreten. In extremen Fällen bis zum Tod.
Ja.
Und was diese geringen Stoffkonzentrationen bedeuten wissen wir nicht. Und ich glaube, da geht es auch gar nicht um akute Folgen, es geht vielleicht um chronische Folgen. Wir haben ja dann auch Stoffe, die endokrin wirksam sind, also wie Hormone wirken. Zu einem Teil sehr niedrigen Konzentrationen, aber das können wir auch nicht einschätzen, was das langfristig bedeutet. Ob die zunehmende Unfruchtbarkeit der Männer damit was zu tun hat oder ob es eher was damit zu tun hat, weil wir bestimmte Stoffe über andere Nahrung aufnehmen oder weil die Männer häufig enge Hosen anhaben und es deshalb um die Hoden zu warm ist. Und da werden wir auch nie von jetzt über die lange Zeitskalen eine klassische Ursache-Wirkungs-Beziehung herstellen können.
Aber in der Tierwelt gibt es solche Erkenntnisse?
In der Tierwelt gibt es zwischenzeitlich jede Menge Befunde, auch Auswirkungen von Arzneimitteln. Also es gibt ein Schmerzmittel, Diclofenak, das wurde lange Zeit in Indien und Pakistan eingesetzt zur Behandlung von Rindern und das hat unter anderem dazu geführt, dass dort drei Geierpopulationen fast ausgestorben wären. Im Moment entscheidet sich gerade, ob die sich wieder erholen, nachdem der Wirkstoff, den auch wir verwenden als Schmerzmittel, nicht mehr eingesetzt wird dort.
Also die Geierpopulation über den Aasfraß sozusagen?
Ja, also die Rinder sind dann verendet und man weiß, dass Diclofenak auch beim Menschen nierentoxisch ist. Jetzt kenne ich mich mit der Geierphysiologie nicht so gut aus, aber man weiß, dass diese geringen Mengen genau dazu geführt haben, dass die da ein Problem hatten und immer mehr gestorben sind. Das noch viel spannendere an diesem Beispiel ist einerseits, dass der Wirkstoff jetzt in Spanien wohl wieder zugelassen wurde und andererseits und das ist mir der viel wichtigere Punkt, dass sogenannte Neuweltgeier, also in Indien, Asien haben wir die sogenannten Altweltgeier. Die Neuweltgeier, der Kondor in Südamerika anscheinend völlig unempfindlich ist gegenüber diesem Stoff. Und das führt dann auf die Frage, können wir denn, werden wir wirklich in der Lage sein, für jede Chemikalien alle möglichen Risiken zu prüfen?
Und meine Schlussfolgerung ist nein. Denn wenn wir überlegen, wir nehmen einen Stoff, dieser Stoff hat vielleicht fünf oder zehn Abbauprodukte in der Umwelt oder in der Kläranlage, dann haben wir allein für Mutagenität, ein ganz wichtiger Toxizitätsendpunkt, einen Test, der heißt Ames-Test. Allein da gibt es schon mindestens acht verschiedene Varianten, wie ich diese Mutagenität bestimmen kann oder bestimmen muss. Dann haben wir haben wir aber noch ganz viel mehr Toxizitätsendpunkte, Gentoxizität, Zelltoxizität. Da gibt es jeweils wieder die ganze Palette von Tests, die alle ihren Sinn machen, weil jeder Test nur ganz bestimmte Dinge abbildet. Das heißt wir sind ganz schnell bei sehr großen Zahlen, allein für einen Stoff. Wenn wir dann denken, wie viele chemische Stoffe haben wir denn auf dem Markt, dann werden wir das Risiko nie abschätzen können und es wird immer wieder Überraschungen geben.
Und auch die Kombinationswirkungen sind ja damit noch lange nicht erfasst. Das heißt für mich und da komme ich jetzt wieder zurück auf meine früheren Dinge mit Zeit und Vorsorge und ähnliches und Risiko, was ich mal gemacht habe auch, stellt sich die Frage, was machen wir damit? Und was ist unser klassisches Weltbild und darin liegt für mich eigentlich die Begründung des Vorsorgeprinzips. Und damit liegt auch drin die Frage, wie kann ich verhindern, das bestimmte Stoffe entweder in die Umwelt gelangen, durch geschicktes Handhaben, durch weniger Stoffe nutzen. Manche werden wir aber weiterhin nutzen müssen und auch sollen, denn sie sind wesentlich für das Funktionieren der Welt, für die Gesundheit für unseren Lebensstandard, darum geht es nicht. Aber dass wenn sie in die Umwelt gelangen beispielsweise sie schnell und vollständig abbaubar sind.
Blieben wir vielleicht nochmal kurz bei den Probleme rund ums Wasser. Jetzt haben wir ja auch hier unsere lokale, teils regionale deutsch-europäische Sicht der Dinge. Wir leben ja hier in verhältnismäßig entspannten Gesamtsituationen, einfach ausgehend aus dieser Eigenschaft dieser gemäßigten Zone, potenziell wasserreich und vielfältig. Andere Bereiche der Welt haben es da viel schwerer. Vor allem die, wo Wasser ohnehin schon knapp ist. Aber das ist denn sagen wir mal jenseits der Knappheit und der konkreten chemischen Verunreinigung, was sind denn noch weitere Probleme, die sich so im Kampf um Wasser mit ...?
Ja also von der Verunreinigung habe ich ja schon mal gesagt, vielleicht das nochmal kurz. Auch die mikrobiologische, also die hygienische Belastung mit Bakterien, Viren etc., in manchen Ländern ein recht großes Problem. Und im Übrigen die Wasserqualität auch für die Industrie unter Umständen bei uns ein Problem. Wenn Sie nämlich hochmoderne Produkte herstellen, dann brauchen Sie hochreines Wasser und auf einmal muss ich mein Wasser ganz anders aufreinigen, ich kriege Folgekosten, ich kriege Abfälle etc.. Was natürlich auch ein Problem ist, einfach durch die Wasserknappheit gibt es auch Verteilungskämpfe, wie bei manchen anderen Ressourcen auch. Wer hat Zugang zum Wasser? Die Frage, ist Wasser ein Allgemeingut? Ist der Anspruch auf sauberes Wasser ein Menschenrecht? Oder ist das ein Gut, das sozusagen ökonomischen Regeln unterliegen kann und muss wie andere Güter auch?
Und wo dann natürlich auf einmal ein Markt ist. Was mich auch bei uns immer amüsiert, dann kommen die Studierenden und andere Leute mit ihrer PET-Flasche oder auch zwischenzeitlich umgefüllt, mit Wasser, Volvic, Evian, wie sie auch alle heißen, das ewig lang transportiert wird und auch nicht letztlich so viel sauberer ist wie unseres. Wenn man bei den Abfüllungen nicht aufpasst, dann hat man es mikrobiologisch kontaminiert oder Monomere können unter Umständen einwandern. Also besser und sauberer und nachhaltiger ist das schon gar nicht.
Also Monomere sind das dann Stoffe aus der Verpackung?
Ja Abbauprodukte oder welche, die gar nicht eingebaut wurden. Und in anderen Ländern habe ich dann ganz massiv, dadurch wenn Wasserknappheit ist, besonders entsprechender Qualität ist das natürlich auch ein riesen Markt. Und das ist eigentlich aus meiner Sicht nicht nachhaltig. Ich denke, bestimmte Güter dürfen nicht dem Markt unterliegen.
Was ist denn der eigentliche Grund für die Verknappung der Süßwasserreserven? Ist das jetzt sozusagen nur die übermäßige Beanspruchung oder verknappen sich diese Reserven in irgendeiner Form selbst?
Also der Planet Erde verliert ja kein Wasser oder kaum Wasser in die Atmosphäre. Es ist die übermäßige Beanspruchung, also Mengen immer mehr, auch an bestimmten Orten immer mehr, zum Teil auch bei uns, wo der Grundwasserspiegel absinkt, weil wir einfach mehr Wasser entnehmen als reinkommt, dann spielt sicher der Klimawandel mit rein. Und eben aber auch die Qualität, dass wir immer mehr Wasser in höherer Qualität brauchen, dass wir immer mehr Menschen werden. Also wenn die Fäkalien von zehn Menschen in einen großen Fluss gehen, ist das kein Problem. Nur wenn da eine Millionenstadt nach der anderen dran ist, dann ist das ein Problem. Und da auch nochmal an der Stelle, ich habe keine grundsätzliche Kritik an Kläranlagen. Der größte medizinische Fortschritt sozusagen war die Erfindung der Kläranlagen. Nämlich die menschlichen Ausscheidungen aus dem Wasser und damit die Krankheitserreger aus dem Wasser rauszunehmen und die Stoffe, die zu dieser Überdüngung führen können zum Teil.
Wir stoßen nur jetzt an die Grenzen, wo wir sagen, die jetzigen Probleme mit den Stoffen, mit den Spurenstoffen, die wir dort drin haben, können wir auch auf diesem Weg lösen. Das wird eine Sackgasse sein, nach meiner Überzeugung oder nach meiner Erfahrung. Also da spielen ganz viele Dinge miteinander rein und wenn ich überall Kläranlagen wollte, habe ich wieder einen entsprechend höheren Energiebedarf. Die Energie ist nicht zur Verfügung. Manchmal auch in manchen Bereichen nicht entsprechend qualifiziertes Personal und wenn ich da eine Hightechanlage habe, braucht die nochmal mehr Energie, macht Folgeprobleme und ich brauche zusätzliche Chemikalien, und ich brauche vielleicht Ersatzteile. Das haben wir ja auch gelernt aus der Entwicklungspolitik der 70/80/90er Jahre. Toll wir bohren einen Brunnen in Afrika und stellen einen Pumpe hin. Nur die läuft vielleicht nach zwei Jahren nicht mehr, weil zu viel Sand reingekommen ist und wer weiß dann, wie man die Pumpe zerlegt? Das Ersatzteil, wenn es denn verfügbar ist, aus- oder einbaut.
Und von daher braucht man auch da ganz andere Zugänge. Da geht es jetzt vielleicht eher um Bildung und sonstige Dinge und um Selbstbefähigung. Aber wir brauchen auch genau deshalb so Ansätze, die am Beginn des Problems ansetzen und nicht nachbehandeln.
Gibt es nicht auch das Problem des Anbohrens von so besonders tiefliegenden Wasserressourcen, die früher noch überhaupt gar nicht haben erreicht werden können und wo quasi Wasserspeicher angezapft werden, die dort seit Millionen Jahren tief in der Erde vor sich hinlagen und andere Probleme mit sich bringen? Ich weiß nicht, ich habe was von radioaktiver Belastung gehört, ist das eine richtige Wahrnehmung?
Das kann es geben. Ja also da muss man dann auch gucken, was ist da geogen, natürlicherweise bedingt drin. Und natürlich sind das alles endliche Ressourcen. Das sind häufig Vorräte, die sich nicht erneuern. Die haben sich im Laufe von vielleicht Jahrzehntausenden gebildet und die werden jetzt innerhalb von wenigen Jahren, da kann man da mal schnell Landwirtschaft machen und andere Dinge, mitten in der Wüste, aufgebraucht. Und die Frage ist, was passiert dann, wenn die zu Ende sind? Und das heißt nicht nur, was passiert dann im Sinne von Bewässerung, sondern was passiert dann auch sozial, ökonomisch in diesen Ländern, global? Wir erleben es ja gerade. Fluchtursachen. Wo wir eigentlich auch gelernt haben, man hätte viel früher dort ansetzen müssen, um die Fluchtursachen zu bekämpfen. Jetzt ist es eigentlich zu spät, jetzt machen wir wieder sozusagen End of the Pipe-Behandlung, indem wir sagen, wir gucken, dass wir die Leute hier integrieren, weil wir gar keine andere Möglichkeiten mehr haben mit all den Probleme. Und denke ich so an der Stelle würde das auch so reinspielen.
Jetzt klingt das ja immer so ein bisschen absurd mit, dass es so wenig Wasser gibt, weil 2/3 des Planeten bestehen ja im Wesentlichen eigentlich nur aus Wasser, aber eben nicht aus Süßwasser. Inwiefern ist denn das Meer da eine Antwort und inwiefern ist das Meer auch schon selber zu einem Problem geworden?
Das Meer ist nur insofern eine Antwort, als wir natürlich das Salzwasser technisch reinigen können, aber diese technische Reinigung dadurch wieder jede Menge Energieaufwand braucht. Und jetzt kann natürlich sagen, und das trifft jetzt für viele Bereiche, das trifft für Ressourcengewinnung, das trifft für Recycling, das trifft für Abwasserbehandlung zu, ja wenn wir alles solar machen haben wir genügend Energie. Aber wir haben nicht unendlich viel Energie. Und solange wir nicht unendlich viel Energie haben, wird vielleicht an einer Stelle die Situation verbessert, aber an anderer Stelle wird sie schlimmer. Beispielsweise indem Abfälle entstehen. Wir kriegen unsere seltenen Erdmetalle, mit denen wir schön nachhaltige Energie machen können, aus China. Der Dreck entsteht in China, den sehen wir gar nicht mehr. Aber es wird immer Entropie entstehen, Unordnung, Verunreinigung, gegen die wir ankämpfen müssen, brauchen wir noch mehr Energie. Was dazu führt, dass ich woanders wieder.
Also meine Solarzelle wächst ja auch nicht auf dem Baum, die muss hergestellt werden. Da gibt es Abfallstoffe, Abwärme etc.. Ja und das scheint mir glaube ich ein zentraler Punkt, den wir viel besser verstehen müssen und das gilt für Wasser auch. Ja wir können Wasser reinigen mit Umkehrosmose, geht technologisch, gar kein Problem, aber wir müssen die Energie haben, wir müssen das KnowHow haben, wir müssen die Materialien und Einrichtungen dafür haben. Und wenn wir das an im großtechnischen Maßstab machen, im globalen, dann brauchen wir da eben nicht nur ein paar Solarzellen dafür.
Aber welche Rolle spielen denn die Meere in dieser ganzen Süßwasserversorgungsfrage? Ist das komplett entkoppelt oder?
Ja die Meere sind eigentlich Teil des Wasserkreislaufs. Also fangen wir an, wir haben Niederschlag, Schnee oder Regen, der geht zum Teil in den Boden oder Überland, versickert, zum Teil verdunstet er wieder, ein Teil fließt ab in die Gewässer, in die Flüsse, Seen, von dort aus ins Meer und im Meer verdunstet das Ganze wieder. Das ist so der Wasserkreislauf. Wir haben eigentlich zwischenzeitlich viele Schadstoffe auch im Meer. Ob das jetzt Arzneimittel sind, auch die kann man nachweisen. Wir haben welche in der deutschen Bucht, in der Nordsee nachgewiesen mit Kollegen zusammen. Und andere haben das in anderen Meeren nachgewiesen. Prominent natürlich das Mikroplastik. Wir stellen fest, Stoffe, die gut fettlöslich sind, in ganz geringen Mengen aber doch wasserlöslich, gelangen in die Nahrungskette über das Zooplankton, dann das Phytoplankton, also ganz kleine Organismen pflanzlicher und tierischer Art und dann in die Fische, die davon leben.
Dann in die Raubfische und letztlich landen sie zum Teil auch wieder bei uns. Also auch da sind wir nicht entkoppelt. Denken wir an das Plastik, ich glaube dass es vielen bekannt zwischenzeitlich, wo wir auf den großen Ozeanen Bereiche haben, wo nicht nur ein halber Quadratkilometer, sondern anscheinend über hunderte/tausende von Quadratkilometern Plastik schwimmt.
Und zwar massenhaft.
Massenhaft. Zum Teil auch absinkt, aber das nicht abbaubar ist. Kunststoff ist ja mit das langlebigste, was wir je hergestellt haben, Plastik.
Gibt es denn da Ansätze, die Meere zu reinigen?
Es gibt natürlich Ansätze, die Meere zu reinigen. Dass man jetzt Schiffe entwickelt, die das abfischen. Aber einerseits können die nur das erwischen was oben ist und andererseits ist das eine riesen Aufgabe und zum dritten das ist wieder End of the Pipe. Also auch da brauchen wir Kunststoffe, da gibt es ja auch Überlegungen und schon Produkte auf dem Markt, aber leider noch viel zu wenig, dass Kunststoffe unter bestimmten Bedingungen biologisch abbaubar sind. Beispielsweise im Wasser schnell und vollständig. Unter anderem das Preisgeld, das ich bekommen habe, verwende ich für eine Doktorarbeit in diesem Bereich, wo wir da ran gehen an so einen Massenkunststoff, gucken, was können wir da lernen, wie weit können wir da kommen oder werden wir da gnadenlos scheitern. Das gehört ja zur Wissenschaft immer auch dazu zur Forschung.
Jetzt sind Sie mir ein bisschen zuvorgekommen, das wollte ich natürlich noch erwähnen, Sie haben den Wasserressourcenpreis erhalten jetzt 2015 im letzten Jahr von der Rüdiger Kurt Bode Stiftung, die auch im Stifterverband organisiert ist. Worum ging es dabei?
Es ging dabei, Wasserressourcenpreis sagt es ja schon, Schutz der Wasserressourcen. Und in dem Fall, dass das Konzept Denied by Design, gutartig durch gezielte Planung, auf Moleküle anwenden, um Moleküle zu machen am Beispiel von Arzneimitteln, aber auch anderen chemischen Stoffen, die jetzt im Fall der Arzneimittel mindestens genauso gut oder besser wirksam sind und auch nicht mehr, sondern idealerweise noch weniger Nebenwirkungen haben als Arzneimittelwirkstoffe, die sie ersetzen sollen. Aber wenn sie in die Umwelt gelangen oder bei uns in die Kläranlage, dort schnell und wichtig vollständig abgebaut werden zu Kohlendioxid und Wasser, mineralisiert wie wir dazu sagen. Und für die Entwicklung dieses Konzepts, aber auch für die Umsetzung. Wir haben noch keine Arzneiwirkstoffe entwickelt, die jetzt auf dem Markt sind.
Da braucht es noch die großen Arzneimittelfirmen. Aber wir haben gezeigt – weil das war immer die Diskussion, entweder haben wir Arzneimittelwirkstoffe, die wirken oder wir haben welche, die in der Umwelt abbaubar sind. Wir haben gezeigt, dass es genauso nicht ist, sondern dass man das gezielt machen kann.
Wie haben Sie das gezeigt?
Indem wir einen ungewöhnlichen Ansatz gewählt haben. Also wir haben uns lange Zeit ja genau mit diesen Abbauprodukten beschäftigt, die bei dieser Abwasserreinigung entstehen. Behandlung mit Licht zum Beispiel, eine Trinkwasserbehandlung. Und haben dann uns immer damit rumgeschlagen, hoppla, da gibt es diese Abbauprodukte, die müssen wir bewerten, die sind vielleicht toxisch, wissen wir nicht welches Risiko.
Also die Abbauprodukte sozusagen das was jetzt am Ende einer Kläranlage …
Übrig bleibt.
Übrig bleibt und irgendwie nicht weggehen will, obwohl schon so viele Maßnahmen biologischer Art ...?
Also Bruchstücke könnte man vielleicht sagen oder das Molekül wurde ein bisschen verändert, wurden irgendwo ein paar Atome dran gehängt, die vorher nicht dran waren. Und dann sind wir auch die Idee gekommen und haben gesagt, ja wir machen zwar keine Synthese im Sinne wie man sich das von der Chemie kennt. Reagenzglas und einen Kolben, habe eine Stoff, gebe einen anderen dazu, erwärme und dann findet da gezielt eine Reaktion statt. Aber mit dem Licht haben wir auch neue Stoffe gemacht beispielsweise oder mit den Bakterien. Und dann haben wir geguckt, welche dieser Stoffe sind gut biologisch abbaubar. Vorher haben wir immer gesagt, ja die, die gut biologisch abbaubar sind, um die brauchen wir uns nicht weiter kümmern. Ist ja kein Risiko mit verbunden von diesen Abbauprodukten.
Geht weg.
Stört nicht.
Ja. Und dann haben wir irgendwann gesagt, hoppla, wenn da jetzt welche dabei sind, die noch wirksam sind, Abbauprodukte, dann wären das ja abbaubare Wirkstoffe. Also haben wir uns die Abbauprodukte angeguckt, wie vorher auch, und einen Abbautest gemacht und dann geguckt, welche verschwinden. Und dann haben wir mit computerbasierten, also mit der Analytik, geguckt, welche chemische Struktur haben die, die verschwunden sind und dann haben wir mit diesen computerbasierten Methoden geguckt, hoppla könnten die noch wirksam sein? Also passen die an die Stelle, an der Stelle im Körper in den Rezeptor, die notwendig ist, damit sie wirken können. Das kann man heutzutage rechnen, am Computer machen. Und dann gibt es noch andere Eigenschaften, bestimmtes Fenster der Löslichkeit, dann bestimmte Giftigkeit darf nicht vorhanden sein.
Und das kann man heutzutage rechnen mit Computern. Ist mit einer gewissen Unsicherheit verbunden, aber man ist da schon vergleichsweise gut.
Ich weiß nicht, sind Sie da in der Lage, nochmal ein konkreteres Beispiel zu nennen von so einem Stoff, den Sie oder so einem Stoffbereich, den Sie sich genauer angeschaut haben, ohne dass wir uns jetzt hier in Molekülstrukturen verfangen?
Weitverbreitete Stoffgruppe Betablocker.
Also die in der Pharmakologie für psychische Belastungen eingesetzt werden?
Nein, es geht um den Bereich der Kardiologie.
Ah okay.
Blutdruckbehandlung und so weiter. Also ist ja relativ weit verbreitet. Typischer Wirkstoffname wäre Propanolol, kennt wahrscheinlich der ein oder andere Hörer. Und das haben wir mit Licht bestrahlt und dann geguckt, welche Bruchstücke entstehen, welche dieser Bruchstücke würden in einer Kläranlage abgebaut, da haben wir einen Test, der das nachstellt.
Wie würde denn dieser, also welcher Behandlung ist denn der Stoff dann in der Kläranlage, was heißt mit Licht bestrahlt? Ist das UV-Licht?
UV-Licht oder auch Sonnenlicht, simuliertes Sonnenlicht. Das hängt vom Molekül ab, was bei welchem geht. Da muss man wissen, wie das Molekül aufgebaut ist und welche Struktur es hat, dann weiß man schon, was passiert mit Sonne, was passiert mit UV.
Also man simuliert im Prinzip diese Stufen der Kläranlagen, so wie sie heutzutage aufgebaut sind?
Ja. Und der erweiterten Abwasserreinigung, die jetzt kommen soll oder die in Diskussion ist. Aber es gibt immer mehr, die sehen, das kann nicht die Lösung sein aus den vorher genannten Gründen. Zum Teil gibt es ja auch Dinge, das haben wir auch gemacht, behandelt mit Ozon, also hochreaktiven Agenz und gedacht hat, das zerstört alle Stoffe, aber wenn man mit chemischem Blick dran geht, dann weiß man, wie Ozon mit Molekülen reagiert und es ist klar, dass das nicht vollständig abgebaut werden kann.
Wie haben sich diese Betablocker dann verhalten?
Da gab es dann Bruchstücke und einige dieser Bruchstücke waren in der Tat biologisch dann abbaubar. Also die würden in der Kläranlage abgebaut, wenn die vorher über Licht gebildet würden. Man kann auch umgekehrt vorgehen, auch da haben wir Beispiele für einen Abbau durch Bakterien in der Anlage, Bruchstücke entstehen, die durch die Bakterien nicht weiter abgebaut werden. Wenn wir die dann mit Licht behandeln gibt es wieder neue Bruchstücke, die vielleicht abgebaut werden. Und dann haben wir geguckt, welche dieser Bruchstücke, die abgebaut werden, sind denn noch aktiv, im Sinne der Motorsubstanz. Eigentlich ist das ja was, was man vermeiden will, dass die Bruchstücke aktiv sind, aber wenn sie biologisch abbaubar sind, wäre das ein Beispiel für einen Stoff, der wirkt und gleichzeitig in der Umwelt biologisch abbaubar ist.
Was meinen Sie mit „noch aktiv“?
Ja Wirkung als Betablocker.
Okay, also in der eigentlichen Wirkung.
In der eigentlichen Wirkung, so wie die Ausgangssubstanz, wie das Propanolol. Und da haben wir dann welche gefunden und dann haben wir die mit computerbasierten Methoden uns die Eigenschaften angeguckt, die wichtig sind für Arzneimittelwirkstoffe. Und dann hatten wir sogar noch Glück, dann haben wir in dem Fall sogar festgestellt, es gibt einen Rezeptor, also Zellen, die man kaufen kann, um zu testen, ob die wirklich eine Wirkung haben. Und das haben wir dann da gemacht und haben festgestellt, hoppla, da gibt es welche, die sind wirklich wirksam. Und nach allem was wir testen konnten, in unserer kleinen Toxikologiegruppe beispielsweise die sind nicht mutagen, ganz wichtiges Kriterium schon.
Das heißt nicht?
Können nicht Krebs auslösen, vereinfacht gesagt. Wir nehmen ja keine Arzneimittel, um Krebs auszulösen. Das ist der Tod eines Arzneimittels sozusagen, eines Wirkstoffes. Und das ist das Konzept, das Konzept sagt, wir müssen Stoffe haben und wir können das auch machen, die wenn sie in die Umwelt gelangen, vollständig biologisch abbaubar sind. Egal was sie für eine Eigenschaft, weshalb wir sie einsetzen. Das Spannende war …
Das war also jetzt ein Positivbeispiel?
Das war ein Positivbeispiel.
Man konnte sozusagen nachweisen, dieser Betablocker ist mit den Methoden, die in der Kläranlage angewendet werden, nachhaltig abzubauen?
Ja also in den klassischen Methoden wird er nicht entfernt aus der Kläranlage. Wenn der in der normalen Kläranlage entfernt würde, der Wirkstoff, der ursprüngliche, das Propanolol, den wir heute auf dem Markt haben, der wird ja nicht entfernt in der Kläranlage, den kann ich überall in der Umwelt messen. Aber diese Variante, die gebildet wird, durch die Behandlung mit Licht und das untypische dran ist, weil normalerweise macht man für einen neuen Wirkstoff eine gezielte Synthese, das haben wir nicht gemacht. Wir haben sozusagen eine Zufallssynthese gemacht. Wir haben gesagt, wir gucken alle Strukturen an, die gebildet werden. Gucken, was ist noch aktiv und was wird abgebaut in der Kläranlage dann, wenn ich das jetzt als Wirkstoff nehmen würde.
Also verstehe ich das jetzt richtig, war jetzt die Empfehlung einerseits, die Kläranlage sollte noch eine zusätzliche Maßnahme ergreifen oder war die Konsequenz, man muss das Arzneimittel anders aufbauen, damit es sich entsprechend verhält?
Konsequenz, da es sich gezeigt hat in vielen Laboruntersuchungen und anderen, dass man, wenn man die Kläranlage verändert, manches Problem nicht löst, sondern nur verschiebt, sogar noch verschlimmert, weil ich mache aus einer Muttersubstanz, die ich eigentlich entfernen will, unter Umständen zwanzig Folgeprodukte. Allein für ein Antibiotikum Ciprofloxacin haben wir recherchiert, was bis 2012 publiziert wurde, gab es 38 verschiedene Folgeprodukte, die in der Literatur beschrieben wurden. Je nach Verfahrenskombination und wie lang die Behandlung war, ob das jetzt mit Licht war, ob das mit Ozon war oder ob das mit elektrischem Strom war. Ganz unterschiedliche und auch im Verlauf der Behandlung, ob ich jetzt 2 Minuten behandle oder eine halb Stunde, ganz unterschiedliche Zusammensetzungen der Folgeprodukte. Das heißt das ist so betrachtet technisch auch gar nicht beherrschbar, nur ein Stoff. Wir haben in Deutschland etwa 3000 Arzneimittelwirkstoffe auf dem Markt, 200 kann man im Moment messen etwa.
Das hängt damit zusammen, weil wenn ich die in der Umwelt messen will oder gar in der Kläranlage muss ich die Analyseverfahren entsprechend anpassen, kosten recht viel Zeit.
Das heißt wenn ich das richtig lese, ist die eigentliche Kernempfehlung in dem Fall zumindest gewesen, wenn man dasselbe Arzneimittel auf eine andere Art und Weise herstellt, unter Beibehaltung der eigentlichen Kernwirkung, schafft man eine Variante, die sich zumindest problemlos abbauen lässt?
Nicht wenn ich das Arzneimittel anders herstelle, sondern wenn ich den Wirkstoff so modifizieren, den aktiven Stoff, der die Wirkung macht, so verändere, dass er weiterhin aktiv ist. Die Wirkung, die ich haben will, und gleichzeitig wenn er in die Kläranlage kommt oder in die Umwelt, schnell und vollständig abbaubar ist. Und das war, ich habe vor 10 Jahren mit dem Konzept angefangen, darüber nachzudenken. Und das waren viele Diskussionen, ja das geht ja gar nicht. Entweder er ist wirksam, dann kamen so Argumente, muss ja eine Haltbarkeit haben oder er ist biologisch abbaubar, das ist ein Widerspruch und da Arzneimittel unbestrittenerweise einen hohen Wert haben, also für uns wichtig sind, können wir da auf die biologische Abbaubarkeit keine Rücksicht nehmen. Das war eines der ersten Argumente. Und wenn wir das machen würden, dann würden wir ja vielen Menschen der Zukunft vielleicht neue Wirkstoffe vorenthalten, können wir ethisch nicht vertreten. Ist in der Tat ein wichtiges ethisches Problem, wurde ich auch mit konfrontiert.
Nur dann fiel mir auf, hoppla, wie viele Wirkstoffe werden eigentlich gar nicht entwickelt, weil der Markt zu klein ist? Ökonomisch zu klein. Denken Sie an Malaria, denken Sie an Lepra, was ja nicht wenige Menschen betrifft. Denken Sie an Aids, die ganzen Diskussionen, kriegen die Menschen jetzt die Arzneimittel zum vernünftigen Preis oder umsonst oder nicht? Also letztlich haben wir gar keine ethische Diskussion, sondern wir haben eine ökonomische Diskussion. Und dann wäre das nächste Argument, ja wir haben sowieso schon zu wenig Wirkstoffe, wenn wir das jetzt auch noch als Kriterium haben, jetzt soll es auch noch in der Umwelt biologisch abbaubar sein. Und wenn man sich die Geschichte der Pharmazie anguckt, dann war es immer so, dass im Lauf der Zeit die Kriterien, die ein Stoff erfüllen muss, also was nicht da sein darf, was da sein muss an Eigenschaften, immer mehr wurden. Wir haben seitdem nicht weniger Wirkstoffe. Ganz klassisches Beispiel Contergan. Nachdem Contergan war, gab es ganz viele neue …
Also dieser, ich weiß nicht, das war ein Mittel …
Thalidomid
Also was war der ursprüngliche Zweck?
Es war ein Schmerzmittel, das in einem ganz bestimmten Fenster, Zeitfenster während der Schwangerschaft eingenommen, Missbildungen verursacht hat.
Großer Skandal in den 50ern...
Großer Skandal ja. Schon vorher. Das war Ende, das war in meiner Generation.
Ende der 60er Jahre.
Also ich kenne einige aus meiner Generation, die Missbildungen haben aus dieser Zeit, die etwa so alt sind wie ich.
Und das war ja auch ein Problem der Komplexität?
Ja gut, man wusste das damals noch nicht. Man hat es vielleicht in dem speziellen Fall, schwer zu sagen, was in Kauf genommen wurde und was wirklich an Wissen da war, noch nicht da war, da bin ich nicht der Experte. Der entscheidende Punkt, auf den es mir ankommt, ist, danach musste man neue Eigenschaften zeigen, dass beispielsweise neuer Wirkstoff keine solche Missbildungen macht. Also das Argument, wenn wir das jetzt berücksichtigen, haben wir ja weniger Wirkstoffe. Wir haben aber seitdem sehr viel mehr Wirkstoffe. Und es gibt viele Studien, die zeigen, wenn solche neue Anforderungen kommen, das häufig ein Innovationstreiber ist. Weil es entsteht eine neue Möglichkeit, zugegebenermaßen vielleicht für andere Spieler auf dem Feld, in diesen Raum zu gehen und zu sagen, ja die die klassischen Arzneimittel machen bisher, die sind einfach zu träge oder zu groß oder was auch immer, klassisches Denken, wir hatten da bisher mit Erfolg. Da sind wir alle so gestrickt, also machen wir so weiter. Und dann können aber andere kommen und sagen, ja wir trauen uns das zu, dieses Problem oder diese erhöhten Anforderungen auch einzubauen.
Und nachdem ich jetzt mal diesen Blick hatte, dann sind mir ganz viele Beispiele aufgefallen. Man lebt manchmal auch vom Zufall. Die älteren Hörer wissen vielleicht noch, Ende der 50er/Anfang der 60er Jahre gab es Schaumberge auf den Kläranlagen. Warum? Damals wurde ein synthetisches Tensid, also ein Stoff, der die Waschreinigung vom Wasser besser macht als Seife, eingeführt und der war nicht biologisch abbaubar. Und da hat er das gemacht, was er machen soll, nämlich er hat Schaum gemacht. Aber das hat damals jeder gesehen. Und damals kam der Gesetzgeber und hat gesagt, liebe Anwender, liebe Hersteller, in fünf Jahren ist das verschwunden oder der Stoff wird verboten. Und dann kamen die mit einem neuen Stoff. Geänderte chemische Struktur, viel besser biologisch abbaubar, wird heute noch 400.000 Tonnen pro Jahr in Deutschland eingesetzt. Sogar gegenüber Wasserorganismen, toxischer giftiger als der Stoff, den er ersetzt hat, aber hervorragend abbaubar. Tolles Beispiel. War einer der Anfänge der Umweltschutzgesetzgebung in Deutschland im Bereich Wasser.
Gibt es denn aus der chemischen oder pharmazeutischen Industrie dann auch dieselbe Aufmerksamkeit für Ihre Arbeit, wie ihn Bode-Stiftung gezeigt hat? Also sind das sozusagen auch Ergebnisse, die dort zur Kenntnis genommen werden?
Sie werden zur Kenntnis genommen. Lange Zeit wurden sie zur Kenntnis genommen als Störung. Das was ich gerade gesagt habe, diese Diskussionen.
Will uns einer die Arbeit schwerer machen.
Da will uns einer die Arbeit schwerer machen. Das kann man ethisch nicht machen, solche Dinge. Zwischenzeitlich würde ich sagen, kann man nicht mehr von der pharmazeutischen oder der chemischen Industrie sprechen, sondern es gibt welche, die da durchaus weiter denken, die dran denken oder wo ich weiß, jetzt auch mal auf mich zukommen und fragen, oder wo ich weiß, die gucken jetzt nochmal ihre alten Daten an, was können wir denn da machen. Die es auch als Möglichkeit sehen. Weil letztlich handelt es sich ja um einen neuen Wirkstoff, den ich habe und damit kann ich gleich auch wieder ein Patent haben und damit kann ich gleich wieder am Markt erfolgreich sein und spätestens dann, wenn der erste grüne Wirkstoff auf dem Markt ist, wird sich das Spiel ändern. Da bin ich überzeugt davon.
Weil sich ja dann mittelfristig ja auch die Gesetzgebung vielleicht anpasst und sagt, das ist jetzt auch mal sicherzustellen, dass solche Anforderungen auch erfüllt werden.
Eben und deshalb war es wichtig, zu zeigen, dass es grundsätzlich geht. Natürlich ist da jetzt noch kein Medikament draus geworden und der Arzneimittelentwicklungsprozess ist ja relativ lang und dann hört man immer Zahlen, ja bis zu einer Milliarde. Das spannende war, auch da wurde ich mal in einer Konferenz angegangen oder gefragt oder gesagt, ja das können wir nicht machen, das wird ja noch teurer. Und ich weiß nicht, da war ich ziemlich spontan, da hat mich dann irgendwie die Wut gepackt, ich sage es wirklich so. Und da habe ich gesagt, ja aber wir wissen doch alle, dass zwei Drittel der Entwicklungskosten neuer Arzneimittel Marketingkosten sind. Und da habe ich gedacht, oh jetzt hast du die dich aber in die Nesseln gesetzt und jetzt wirst du gleich was zu hören bekommen. Nein, Stille, hat keiner widersprochen. Also ich habe keine Zahlen dadrüber, aber anscheinend war es nicht falsch oder vielleicht ist es sogar noch mehr. Also wenn all die neuen Wirkstoffe so gut wären. Und dann gibt es ja auch Bereiche von Wirkstoffen. Heißt dann immer, wir haben keine neuen Moleküle, aber es gibt Bereiche von Wirkstoffen, da haben wir Molekülvarianten.
Bei den Sartanen, das ist eine Gruppe Blutfettsenker, da haben wir glaube ich acht oder zehn verschiedene Moleküle auf dem Markt.
Das heißt, das …
Es gibt Möglichkeiten, es gibt Möglichkeiten, diese Molekülstrukturen zu variieren. Es gibt Möglichkeiten für die Varianten. Wo das nachher dann wirklich geht oder nicht, das wird sich zeigen. Aber auch hier ist mir nochmal wichtig, ich hatte das gesagt mit dem veränderten Blick auf diese Waschmittelinhaltsstoffe, Zufall spielt manchmal eine Rolle. Ich habe mich beschäftigt mit Zytostatika in der Umwelt und wurde deshalb eingeladen, beim Krebsforschungszentrum in Heidelberg einen Vortrag zu halten über Zytostatika in der Umwelt. Also Mittel zur Krebsbehandlung. Habe ich gemacht und am Ende des Vortrags sind die auf mich zugekommen und haben gesagt, Sie haben da ein Molekül gezeigt, da haben wir eine Variante. Die haben wir entwickelt, um die Nebenwirkungen zu reduzieren. Was glauben Sie denn, ist das auch biologisch abbaubar in der Umwelt? Da sage ich, ja so wie Sie das verändert haben nach meiner Erfahrung, könnte sein, da ist ein Zucker dran, ein bestimmter Zucker, wahrscheinlich geht es, aber wir müssen das gesamte Molekül anschauen.
Haben die mir ein paar Milligramm mitgegeben, wir haben unseren Test gemacht und es ist wunderbar abbaubar. Und dann hat es aber nochmal eine Weile gedauert, um genau auf die Idee zu kommen, hoppla, weil ich war ja vorher auch so ausgebildet und sozialisiert, ein Stoff hat stabil zu sein, dass er auf den Markt kommt und erfolgreich ist. Aber ich muss fragen, wann und wo in seinem Lebensweg – wir kommen wir zurück auf die Lebenswegbetrachtung. Auf dem Regal, wo kein Licht hinkommt, oder wo Licht hinkommt, aber keine Feuchtigkeit ist, da sind andere Bedingungen. Und wenn das Licht stört, dann kommt es in Braunglas. Sie können ja mal schauen, wie viele Arzneimittel in der braunen Flasche oder im braunen Blister auf dem Markt sind. Oder ich kann mich noch erinnern, bei unseren Kindern, die hatten mal Amoxicillin, ein Antibiotikum bekommen als Pulver. Und da Kinder, kleine Kinder sich ja noch schwer tun, so was zu schlucken, gibt es das als Pulver und da hieß es, aufschlämmen im Wasser. Habe ich gemacht oder haben wir auch gemacht und dann in den Kühlschrank stellen.
Ja warum in den Kühlschrank stellen? Damit sich es nicht so schnell zersetzt. Und da haben wir auch da nochmal geguckt und haben festgestellt, hoppla es gibt ja schon 10-12 Beispiele und wir haben noch nicht alle Wirkstoffe angeguckt, die ohne Absicht gut biologisch abbaubar sind. Also da stimmt es nicht, Stabilität und biologische Abbaubarkeit in der Umwelt ist grundsätzlich ein Widerspruch, sondern es ist eine Frage, wie schaue ich darauf.
Was sind denn so heutzutage, also inwiefern haben Sie Kenntnis, oder inwiefern vermuten Sie das auch nur, was sind sozusagen die wirklich problematischen Stoffe, Chemikalien oder Arzneien, wo es klar ist oder wo man zumindest einen begründeten Verdacht hat, dass das jetzt vielleicht auch so die ersten wären, die man sich mal vielleicht auch mit Ihrer Methode genauer anschauen sollte?
Man kann jetzt zwei Kriterien nehmen, das eine ist sozusagen, oder drei, Giftigkeit. Zytostatika haben keine große Menge, aber sind vergleichsweise sehr giftig. Wenn wir die im Trinkwasser hätten, wäre das wirklich ein Problem. Und in manchen Gegenden, auch in Deutschland, finden wir Arzneimittel im Trinkwasser.
Zytostatika sind wofür im Einsatz?
Zytostatika für die Krebsbehandlung. Aber Röntgenkontrastmittel, also wenn Sie zum Arzt gehen und die Blutgefäße sollen sichtbar gemacht werden, dann müssen Sie was schlucken, so wie Sie für den Darm, da nimmt man ein anorganisches Salz, Bariumsulfat, Schwerspat und da braucht man organische Moleküle. Die sind sogar darauf optimiert, dass sie im Körper nicht abgebaut werden, und unverändert ausgeschieden werden. Die sind auch von der Menge nicht so bedeutend, aber sind ganz persistent, stabil in der Umwelt. Also das wäre ein Kriterium. Und dann, wenn wir uns beispielsweise Antibiotika anschauen, Stichwort Resistenz, wir wissen nicht, ich sage bewusst, wir wissen nicht, es geht wieder um Vorsorge im Moment, welche Rolle hat eigentlich die Gegenwart von Antibiotika in der Umwelt. Antibiotika wirken auf Bakterien. Die Hauptreinigungsstufe in Kläranlagen geschieht durch Bakterien. Resistenz kann übertragen werden.
Im Moment sieht es so aus, als ob ein großer Teil dessen, was ich an resistenten Bakterien in der Kläranlage finde, aus der Anwendung herrührt, aber auch wenn sich bestimmte Antibiotika in der Umwelt anreichern und das kann passieren bei manchen aufgrund ihrer Eigenschaften, kriege ich auch da unter Umständen eine Konzentration, die so hoch ist, dass resistente Bakterien selektiert werden. Also würde ich sagen, Antibiotika ist eine wichtige Gruppe. Und dann alle Stoffe, ja Psychopharmaka, da gab es letztes Jahr eine interessante Studie aus Schweden. Die haben praktisch das Wasser eines Flusses genommen, ins Labor umgeleitet durch ein Aquarium, wo sie Fische hatten, war ein größeres Aquarium und haben dann festgestellt, hoppla, das Schwarmverhalten ändert sich. Und dann haben sie auch noch ein bisschen zudosiert, in umweltrelevanter Konzentration, ein Psychopharmakon und was ist passiert? Die Fische, die einen wurden viel – wie soll man sagen – mutiger. Da es aber keine Raubfische waren, heißt die Gefahr, dass sie gefressen werden, ist viel größer.
Auch das sind Effekte, die wir langfristig nicht feststellen können und sagen, wegen den Arzneimitteln ist jetzt da der Fischbestand zurückgegangen. Aber es kann und wird dazu beitragen. Also deshalb das ist auch nochmal wichtig, wenn wir drauf warten, bis wir exakt den Ursache-Wirkungs-Zusammenhang haben, wie im klassischen wissenschaftlichen Verständnis, werden wir an der Stelle nicht weiterkommen. Und auch da gibt es Beispiele. Bei Krebs haben wir einerseits Zusammenhänge, über Epidemiologie, statistische Verfahren, aber auch in vielen anderen Bereichen sagen wir ja auch, wir wissen, der Stoff ist krebserregend, wir wissen nicht, wie viele Menschen das mal betreffen wird, aber wir sorgen dafür, dass dieser Stoff nicht in den Nahrungsmittelkreislauf kommt oder dass im Arbeitsleben die Menschen damit in Kontakt kommen etc.. Und so müssen wir da auch vorgehen. Und dann Gruppe für Gruppe. Also Menge, Toxizität und spezielle Eigenschaften, wie hormonartig wirkende Stoffe oder synthetische Hormone und Antibiotika wären für mich mal Psychopharmaka die Hauptgruppen.
Also es wendet sich vor allem erst mal an die pharmazeutische Industrie, aber es hat auch was zum Beispiel mit den Kläranlagen auch selber zu tun, die quasi durch die dort eingesetzten Stoffe natürlich auch dazu beitragen, dass unter Umständen Resistenzen herausgebildet werden?
Ja aber da wiederum muss ich gucken, dass ich die Antibiotika gar nicht in die Kläranlagen lasse oder dass sie dort zumindest schnell und vollständig abgebaut werden und nicht da eine lange Verweilzeit haben oder gar ins Oberflächengewässer und dann ins Sediment, also die Ablagerungen im Fluss gelangen etc.. Es geht aber nicht nur um Arzneimittel. Dieses Konzept Denied by Design ist viel breiter. Also klar ist, es geht auch um andere Chemikalien. Nehmen wir zum Beispiel Flammschutzmittel.
Also Denied by Design, das ist ja Ihr ausgerufenes Motto sozusagen immer.
Das ist das Forschungsprogramm.
Ihrer Arbeit so ein bisschen eine, wie soll man das übersetzen, eine wohlwollender Grundansatz bei der Herstellung.
Beziehungsweise dass ich Moleküle gezielt so mache, dass sie „gutartig“ sind. Gutartig im Sinne von, wenn sie in die Umwelt gelangen, schnell und vollständig abbaubar. Dass nichts übrig bleibt, außer Wasser und Kohlendioxid sozusagen. Und das gilt eigentlich für alle chemischen Stoffe, die entweder gezielt – denken Sie an Inhaltsstoffe von Wasch- und Reinigungsmitteln, Kosmetika, aber auch unbeabsichtigt aber unvermeidlich in die Umwelt gelangen. Sie haben hier ein Notebook stehen, da sind unter anderem Flammschutzmittel drin, damit wenn irgendein Kurzschluss ist, die Platine nicht gleich abfackelt. Das gleiche haben Sie aber auch in Ihrem Schlafanzug oder die Damen in ihrem Nachthemd, wenn man das heutzutage noch trägt. In der Bettwäsche. Dass wenn es denn brennen würde, es nicht so schnell zur Entflammung kommt. Und diese Stoffe, die
wir da drin haben, die sind persistent. Also das wäre nochmal ein Kriterium, Stoffe die persistent sind in der Umwelt. Stoffe, die schon gut biologisch abbaubar oder abbaubar sind in der Umwelt vollständig, da müssen wir uns gar nicht weiter mit beschäftigen.
Und ist denn das Verständnis davon, was wirklich persistent ist in der Umwelt, überhaupt umfassend genug oder ist an der Stelle überhaupt nochmal Grundlagenforschung zu tätigen?
Da gibt es schon ein relativ breites Verständnis, das haben die letzten 30 Jahre Umweltchemie gezeigt. Und da gibt es ja sogar internationale Konventionen für die ganz persistenten, die sogenannten POPs, Persistent Organic Pollutants, persistente organische Verbindungen. Die da auf einer Liste stehen, Stockholm-Konvention heißt das Ganze, die dann auch kaum mehr oder nicht mehr verwendet werden dürfen. Aber es gibt viele Stoffe, die diese ganz strengen Kriterien nicht erfüllen und an die müssen wir auch dran. Und das Ziel muss, wir brauchen eigentlich eine Positivliste, dass wir sagen, die die schnell, das heißt innerhalb von Stunden, in der Kläranlage und sagen wir mal innerhalb von Tagen in der Umwelt vollständig abbaubar sind, die dürfen verwendet werden. Und wir denken zur Zeit eher an Zeiträume wie ein Monat oder zwei. Das hängt davon ab, ob Wasser oder Boden. Und vor allem selbst wenn sie abbaubar sind, heißt das meistens nur, wir nennen das Primärabbaubarkeit.
Also die Muttersubstanz ist nicht mehr da, aber die Folgeprodukte, über die wir schon die ganze Zeit sprechen, sind immer noch da. Und dann geht es weiter mit diesem Konzept Denied by Design, wie mache ich eigentlich Produkte insgesamt? Wie muss ich Produkte gestalten, damit sie überhaupt recyclebar sind? Im Moment haben wir ja die große Diskussion über Recycling und Circular Economy, alles im Kreislauf führen. Erstens muss ich mir die Frage stellen, wie kriege ich eigentlich die gefährlichen Stoffe da raus, die wir im Umlauf haben. Die zweite Frage ist, wenn ich das alles im Kreislauf führe, das geht auch nicht ohne Energie. Und wo ich Energie brauche, habe ich irgendwo immer Auswirkungen, die wir in der Chemie Entropie nennen oder in der Physik. Also entsteht Unordnung oder entstehen Probleme. Also von daher wird es nicht funktionieren. Der wahre Kern dran ist, dass ich dadurch manche Produkte doch recyclen kann, vorausgesetzt ich kann sie gut und vollständig einsammeln. Und dann muss ich sie aber auch gezielt so machen, damit ich sie überhaupt zerlegen kann.
Beispielsweise mechanisch und da sind wir schon wieder einen Schritt weiter vorne. Wenn ich sie gut zerlegen kann, früher war im Kühlschrank vieles geschraubt. Heutzutage ist alles geklebt. Im Auto auch. Was geklebt ist, kriege ich häufig gar nicht mehr auseinander. Was geschraubt ist, da kann ich auch mal ein Ersatzteil leichter austauschen. Gehen wir eine Ebene tiefer. Funktionswerkstoffe, Hochleistungskunststoffe beispielsweise, die man unter anderem nimmt, um Sprit zu sparen, weil das Auto leichter wird. Aber das ist häufig nicht der reine sozusagen Kunststoff, da ist nicht nur eine Molekülsorte drin, sondern mehrere. Wenn ich die auf molekularer Ebene durchmische, ist es ganz schwierig, die auseinanderzukriegen. Manche kann ich recyclen, manche kann ich nicht recyclen. Immer vorausgesetzt, ich kann sie einsammeln. Was ja auch Energie kostet und Aufwand, auch sozial organisiert sein muss. Es muss sich rechnen ökonomisch. Und all das ist eigentlich, wie gestalte ich Stoffströme in ihrer Zusammensetzung, ist Denied by Design.
Beispielsweise möglichst geringe Materialvielfalt. Und wir wissen auch, wenn wir die Thermodynamik zu Ende denken, je größer die Stoffströme sind, also je mehr Megatonnen pro Jahr sozusagen durch die Welt gehen, desto mehr werde ich verlieren. Desto mehr Energie muss ich aufwenden, um das überhaupt vernünftig zu managen, zu steuern. Sei es elektrische Energie, Transportenergie, aber auch Energie im Sinne von Management. Dass Leute danach gucken, dass man Konzepte entwickelt. Und wir werden nicht alles recyclen können und für umsonst schon gar nicht.
Wenn Sie jetzt mal zurückblicken auf die Arbeit, die Sie jetzt hier gemacht haben, insbesondere auch in diesem interdisziplinären Kontext, und auch welche Erfahrungen Sie gemacht haben mit der Industrie und anderen relevanten Bereichen der Gesellschaft, was für Lehren haben Sie sozusagen gezogen auch für die konkrete Organisation Ihrer Arbeit? Welche Kommunikation ist erforderlich, welcher Erfahrungen haben Sie gemacht, wie Sie sich hier sozusagen aufstellen in der Wirkung? Weil letzten Endes machen Sie das ja jetzt nicht zum Selbstzweck, sondern es geht Ihnen ja auch um gewisse Resultate?
Sie haben ja sicher gemerkt, oder ich merke es dann immer hinterher und nehme mir dann beim nächsten Interview bist du aber mehr der Wissenschaftler, nicht so engagiert. Aber es gelingt mir nicht, es ist mir auch ein Herzensanliegen. Aber ich glaube, das ist vielleicht ein wichtiger Punkt, zumindest wird mir das dann manchmal zurückgespielt, ja das ist authentisch, da scheint jemand ein Anliegen zu haben. Wichtig ist natürlich, dass man fair und offen mit den Gruppen umgeht, mit denen man zu tun hat. Also wir hatten auch Projekte, wo wir sogenannte Stakeholder-Prozesse drin hatten, ich hatte auch mit Sozialwissenschaftlern zusammengearbeitet. Also welche, die von solchen Maßnahmen betroffen sind, dann versucht, an den Tisch zu holen und offen und fair miteinander diskutiert. Und ich glaube, das werden wir auch weiterhin brauchen. Die Herausforderung ist einerseits fachlich, nach wie vor gut und exzellent zu sein.
Klar einerseits hängt da das Renommee in den Fachwissenschaften ab, aber einfach auch, dass man gute und tragfähige Lösungen macht und nicht nur irgendwas blumiges daherkommt. Gleichzeitig aber auch offen ist für anderes und ein Gefühl dafür hat, zumindest in dem Bereich, wo ich bin, zu sagen, hier das findet ja in einem Kontext statt. Und auch das, was wir jetzt hier machen, finde ich ganz interessant und auch wichtig. Wir werden ja zum allergrößten Teil von öffentlichen Geldern bezahlt und dann sollen die Leute auch wissen, was wir machen einerseits und andererseits verbreiten sich Ideen ja sonst, gerade heutzutage ist das immer schwieriger, ja nicht weiter. Heißt gar nicht, dass alle das ganz toll finden sollen, am meisten habe ich gelernt, wenn es Widerspruch gab. Das sind glaube ich so ganz wichtige Punkte, dass man da offen ist dafür und auch gedanklich wie auch immer rausgeht. Ich komme nochmal drauf zurück, wer nur was von Chemie versteht, versteht auch die nicht.
Also das heißt gar nicht, dass ich die Welt draußen alles verstehe, ich bin kein Psychologe. Aber dass ich offen bin dafür, und was sagen die mir. Oder versuche, wenn ich mit anderen zu tun habe, aus denen ihrer Sicht zu verstehen, was die meinen oder was denen wichtig ist. Was nicht heißt, dass ich verstecken muss, was mir wichtig ist. Weil letztlich geht es ja in den Bereichen, wo ich dann tätig bin, dass man vielleicht auch zu einer Umsetzung kommt. Aber auch da wieder zwiespältig. Ich glaube wir sind heute ein bisschen in der Gefahr, dass wir zu sehr nur an Umsetzung denken. Kaum habe ich eine Idee muss ich ja schon belegen, wenn ich Fördergeld will, ich übertreibe, dass das auch in 5 Jahren oder in Jahren dann in der Praxis ist. Kommt ich auch nochmal auf Albert Einstein zurück, der hat ja seinen Nobelpreis nicht für die Relativitätstheorie bekommen, sondern für die Entdeckung oder Erläuterung, Erklärung des fotoelektrischen Effekts. Ohne diese Erklärung hätten wir keine Elektronik, kein gar nichts heutzutage.
Aber der hat sich nicht primär dafür interessiert, was wird da mal anwendbar sein, oder werde ich in 3 Jahren eine Firma gründen. Und gleichzeitig, ohne mich jetzt damit vergleichen zu wollen, da sind nochmal Welten dazwischen, hat er das was ihm wichtig war entgegen aller Konventionen ein Stück weit nachverfolgt. Er war an einer Institution, die nicht groß bekannt war. Das Berner Patentamt. Hatte aber Freiraum, seinen Ideen nachzuhängen und eben nicht gleich getrieben, was kommt da jetzt raus, was ist verwertbar. Ich sehe da zunehmend ein Problem, weil die Gefahr ist, dass wir uns da zunehmend im Kreis drehen und nur noch sozusagen more of the same und Detailverbesserungen haben, anstatt völlig neue Ansätze, zumindest wagen zu denken. Wissenschaft funktioniert ja nicht so, dass ich morgens aufstehe, eine Idee habe und abends weiß ich, die ist gut, sondern da muss man ja zum Teil ganz dicke Bretter bohren. Und die dicken Bretter muss man manchmal auch bohren oder musste ich bohren im Bereich von dem was ich mach. Weil es relativ unkonventionell war. Und das wäre jetzt auch nochmal was …
Also im chemischen Bereich meinen Sie jetzt?
Im chemischen Bereich ja, dass man sagt, also Moleküle oder Arzneimittel und wir haben uns bewusst, zum einen weil wir da viele Erkenntnisse erworben haben im Laufe der Zeit, aber auch weil ich gesagt habe, wenn wir zeigen können, dass es bei den kompliziertesten Stoffen funktioniert, wo die Anforderungen am höchsten sind, dann kann keiner sagen, es funktioniert woanders nicht. Also Anforderungen an sich selber haben, wohl wissend man kann da auch scheitern. Und wird sich dann zeigen, wie weit wir kommen. Aber sozusagen den Mut zu haben – das erzähle ich natürlich jetzt retrospektiv, da gab es immer wieder Anfechtungen, ja geht das, kannst du das machen, sowohl in mir selber als auch von Kolleginnen und Kollegen. Ja was macht denn der da, das kann ja nicht funktionieren - den Mut zu haben, wenn man davon überzeugt ist, dran zu bleiben. Nicht im Sinne von verbohrt oder verbiestert, sondern gucken, Argumente sammeln, andere Blickwinkel einnehmen, gibt es da vielleicht Bestätigungen, Widersprüche.
Ich habe so ein paar Beispiele genannt, wo man dann manchmal auch vom Zufall lebt. Und für die jungen Leute würde ich eher sagen, nicht alles einer Karriereplanung unterwerfen. So kommt es ja heute häufig daher. schon bei der ersten Klausur in der Schule oder dann in der Universität und wenn die schief geht, dann fehlen mir nachher 1/10, der den Knick in der Karriere machen kann. Ich habe häufig aus meiner Sicht, ich kann nur für mich sprechen, vielleicht ist die Welt heute eine andere, ich habe häufig das gemacht, was mich interessiert hat. Und hinterher manchmal auch gedacht, oh. Insbesondere später, wenn du jetzt eine akademische Karriere machst ist das nicht förderlich. du gehst zu den Medizinern, du bist kein richtiger Mediziner. Du bist aber auch von den Chemikern aus betrachtet kein richtiger Chemiker mehr, wahrscheinlich keine Chance auf eine Professur auf Dauer oder wie auch immer oder mal Institutsleitung. Gut die Wirklichkeit ist jetzt eine andere klar, weil der Zufall eine Rolle gespielt hat, aber der spielt auch eine Rolle, wenn Sie die Karriere exakt planen.
Kann man vielleicht sogar fast sagen, dass die neue Diversifizierung die neue Spezialisierung ist? Dass sozusagen gerade der fachübergreifende Blick eine Qualität ist, die in zunehmendem Maße Bedeutung erfährt? Gerade weil die Kombination aller Disziplinen klar in gewisser Hinsicht sogar auch erforderlich ist, um überhaupt noch Fortschritte zu erzielen?
Ja und nein. Wir brauchen immer, und ich glaube auch in der einzelnen Person, eine Expertise. Nehmen wir ein Bild dafür, Fußball. Ich brauche ein Standbein und ich brauche ein Spielbein. Klar, wenn ich nur ein Bein habe, ist das ganz schwierig. Und wenn ich nur am wild durch die Gegend rennend bin, kein Standbein mehr habe, dann wird es auch beliebig. Aber sich dieser Herausforderung zu stellen und nicht nur in dem ganz engen Bereich an die Expertise zu denken oder denken zu müssen. Oder Mensch ich muss unbedingt noch Nature oder Science publizieren, was auch immer das dann heißt, das glaube ich ist wichtig, sich dieser Herausforderung zu stellen und sich damit auseinanderzusetzen. Und insofern stimme ich Ihnen zu, zu wissen, es geht nicht nur im Detail fachliche Exzellenz, sondern vielleicht ist die manchmal besser, wenn die nicht ganz so gut ist, aber da dafür die Bereitschaft da noch ein bisschen hinter die Kulissen zu schauen oder über den Tellerrand und sich darauf einzulassen. Und das wieder ist glaube ich der Kern des Abenteuers, das man Wissenschaft nennt.
Haben Sie ein Gefühl dafür, wie die Universität jetzt hier auch konkret in Lüneburg mit diesem, ich nenne es jetzt mal Experiment, dieser Diversifizierung, wie da die innere Wahrnehmung gewesen ist, wie die Erfahrungen sind? Ist das sozusagen ein Modell, was in zunehmendem Maße auch vielleicht für andere Bereiche angedacht wird oder ist das etwas, was eigentlich eher aus den Spezialbereichen selbst herauskam und kommen müsste?
Auch da wieder, wahrscheinlich braucht es beides. Also einerseits, da wo die Zeit reif ist und der Boden fruchtbar ist, dass es aus den Spezialbereichen rauskommen kann, ja. Und gleichzeitig gibt es natürlich auch den Zugang von Außen, wo man sagt, aha also nicht aus einer Disziplin heraus, sondern aus mehreren heraus, die sagen, hoppla, wir müssen da zusammen oder wir wollen da zusammen was tun. Das war der Ansatz hier, vielleicht auch ein bisschen aus der Not geboren. Aber ich denke, soweit ich das wahrnehme und was ich zurückgespielt bekomme, sowohl innerhalb der Universität als auch nach außen wird das durchaus wahrgenommen, dass wir hier ein bisschen einen anderen Zugang haben. Wird ganz unterschiedlich wahrgenommen, an manchen Stellen mit viel Skepsis, an manchen Stellen ganz toll. Beides macht mich nachdenklich. Weil es gibt nichts, was nur toll ist und es gibt aber auch nichts, wo man nur skeptisch sein muss, sondern man braucht eine gute Auseinandersetzung damit. Und dann muss man sehen, wo macht das Sinn und wo macht es keinen Sinn.
Wenn ich einen neuen Transistor konstruiere, reicht es vielleicht, wenn ich weiß, es gibt ein paar Punkte, die ich beachten, dass hinterher dieses Produkt kein Problem macht beim Recycling. Also werde ich mir vielleicht Gedanken machen über das Recycling. Da muss ich nicht unbedingt der breite Nachhaltigkeitswissenschaftler sein oder mit Ökonomen zusammenarbeiten. Und in anderen Bereichen kann es vielleicht sein, dass es viel wichtiger ist, nehmen wir Textilien, ein Textildesigner ist mein Beispiel immer, eigentlich müsste der, der die Textilien designed, die hinterher auch zurücknehmen und gucken, wie er die wieder recycled kriegt oder weiter verwendet kriegt, dann würde er das ganz anders machen. Insofern typische Wissenschaftler Antwort, jain, insofern es gibt nicht die eine beste Lösung, sondern es gibt wahrscheinlich mehrere und bisher sind wir allerdings in vielen Bereichen noch ganz streng, ganz streng disziplinär ausgerichtet und es ist ganz schwierig für die, die in den Disziplinen sind, da vielleicht auch rauszukommen.
Weil sie ja nach den disziplinären Kriterien ganz eng beurteilt werden. Manchmal auch nichts anderes sehen wollen aus guten Gründen. Geht uns ja allen so. Ich denke, da kann sicher und muss sicher noch mehr passieren. Aber wir sollten nicht versuchen, das eine gegen das andere auszuspielen. Wir brauchen wirklich beides. Zum Teil in den einzelnen Personen. Was natürlich ein gewisser Mehraufwand sein kann. Aber wie ich zu Beginn gesagt habe, auch eine Bereicherung.
Gefühlt haben wir jetzt auch so die ganze Zeit eigentlich viel über Forschung geredet. Und letztlich ist ja auch die Lehre hier noch ein wichtiger Aspekt. Wenn wir jetzt diese breite Aufstellung mit mehreren Standbeinen sozusagen ausgestattet, Disziplinen auch weiterdenkt, auch für die Lehre, welche Konsequenzen sollte das im Lehrbereich, im Lehrbetrieb haben? Müsste man im Prinzip schon sehr viel interdisziplinärer die Studenten an die Themenbereiche heranführen und sagen, wenn du Chemie machst, dann musst du dir auf jeden Fall mal die Philosophie anschauen?
Ja das kann ein Punkt sein. Also wir machen das so. Nicht bis zur Philosophie, aber die Studierenden fangen bei uns relativ breit an im Bachelor. Wir haben ja in der Fakultät Humanwissenschaften und Naturwissenschaften und die fangen da etwa gleichgewichtet an. Können dann zum Teil spezialisieren bis zum Ende des Bachelors, aber es wird auch am Ende des Bachelors nie so sein, dass sie nur Chemie machen. Das heißt ich bilde auch keine klassischen Chemiker aus, sondern ich bilde welche aus, die vielleicht relativ viel von Chemie wissen, aber auch noch ein bisschen zumindest sich mit anderen unterhalten können. Dafür am einen oder anderen Punkt vielleicht Defizite in der Chemie haben. Aber wenn ich mir heute chemische Landschaft anschaue, dann haben wir häufig das Bild vom Chemiker, der Synthese macht im Kopf. Wichtiger Teil. Aber es gibt ja auch viele, die chemische Analytik machen. Die brauchen gar nicht so viel Synthesechemie zu können. Klar, die können dann später nicht mehr alles machen. Aber den Allroundchemiker gibt es wahrscheinlich eh nicht mehr.
Wie es auch den Universalwissenschaftler in der Form eigentlich kaum noch gibt.
Aber natürlich ist auch für einen Analytiker oder Synthetiker wichtig, dass er Dinge drumherum kennt. Also wenn es um Synthese geht, dass er was gehört hat von den Konzepten der grünen Chemie, die es da gibt. Wie kann ich die Nachhaltigkeit oder Umweltfreundlichkeit einer Synthese beurteilen, jenseits von Begriffen wie Ausbeute. Da gibt es einige Konzepte. Und das müssen wir auch in den normalen Chemiestudiengang mehr reinbringen. Wir brauchen das hier nicht so, weil wir keine Synthese machen, aber dafür sind bei uns andere Konzepte wichtig in der Chemie. Aber wir machen eben nicht nur Chemie, sondern die hören auch was in Ökologie, die hören was in Umweltrecht, die können unterschiedlich vertiefen. Es gibt welche, die bis zum Schluss diese Balance Naturwissenschaften, Humanwissenschaften haben, das sind ideale Leute, die dann an Schnittstellen arbeiten in Unternehmen beispielsweise in der Nachhaltigkeitskommunikation. Und die können mit einem Grundwissen an Chemie mit dem Chemiker sprechen, aber gleichzeitig auch mit dem Juristen oder dem Ökonomen.
Und das ist das Modell, was wir hier haben. Und ich glaube, da stoßen wir in neue Bereiche vor. Gleichzeitig innerhalb der Chemie eben nicht klassische Chemie, sondern nachhaltige Chemie. Und da braucht man bestimmte Kenntnisse aus der Chemie. Andere braucht man vielleicht nicht, aber wir brauchen auch Kenntnisse beispielsweise zur Toxikologie. Wir wollen ja toxische Moleküle vermeiden. Und insofern verschwimmen da ein bisschen die Grenzen, was aber nicht heißen muss, dass die solide fachliche Ausbildung schlechter wird. Sondern der Wissenskanon ist vielleicht schmaler, aber das was noch da ist, muss genauso gut und genauso tragfähig sein.
Und am Ende steht da vielleicht ein ganz neues Institut und eine Professur mit einer Stellenbeschreibung, wie es sie noch gar nicht gibt.
Wer weiß, die Zukunft ist offen.
Ist Ihnen ja auch so gegangen. Herr Kümmerer vielen Dank für die Ausführungen.
Ganz meinerseits.
Hier zur Gesamtfrage Wasser und Chemie und unsere Umwelt und auch natürlich unsere Gesellschaft und auch die wissenschaftliche Arbeit am Ende. Ja und ich sage auch wieder vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier bei Forschergeist, bald geht es weiter und bis dahin sage ich tschüss und bis bald.